the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club following three spectacular
European events the 2023 Grand chess
tour returned to American soil for its
penultimate leg the St Louis rapid and
Blitz the final rapid and Blitz event
left players with one more opportunity
to showcase their skills in the faster
time controls this time in the capital
of Chess in the US Maxim vasher 's hands
were on fire as the Frenchman scorched
the field on his way to Soul first going
into the final day however after a
flurry of lead changes and several
clutch performances it came down to the
final round with Fabiano Carana holding
a draw against the former World Blitz
Champion that secured the win after a
sterling win at the super bet chess
classic to start off the season Carana
hopes to end it as Grand chess tour
Champion going into the final event he
sits in pole position but still has one
more challenge ahead as the entire tour
field reunites to battle it out one last
time at the singfield cup in St Louis
for the Epic conclusion to the 2023
Grand chest
[Music]
tour
welcome to round one of the s SFI C the
conclusion of the grand chest tour it's
the last tournament of the tour and
everything is on the line the history
will be made let's go to the studio and
start the
tournament welcome to Saint Louis the
home of Chess in America as the St Louis
chess club proudly presents the sink
field cup the last stop on this year's
Grand chest T and it starts right
now
hello and welcome and this is it the
sinkfield cup the fifth and final stop
on the grand chest Tor it will be where
Fates and Futures are determined sounds
dramatic that's because it is I'm
International master yanah housea and
it's a great pleasure to be alongside
and commenting all the action young
grandm yes is Sarah Jo nice nice to have
you back in studio and also Peter nice
to have you with us in studio what do
you think of the new place that's so
fancy isn't it great it's good oh it
does hello everyone and Welcome to our
live coverage of the sink field cup the
granddaddy of them all as we like to say
the final event on the grand chest tour
and we will be crowning champions of the
sinkfield cup as well as a grand chest
tour but one man has taken the mystery
out of who's going to be the winner this
year Joy I mean it has been a
spectacular year for Fabiano it
certainly has now he might have taken
away the mystery but the drama and the
action and the suspense it's still there
because grandmas Fabiano caruana he did
win the 2023 St Louis rapid and Blitz
and this not only netted him
$40,000 to the good but also 13 Grand
chest tour points and those 13 points
means that there Fabiano Carana with 33
points has an almost unassailable lead
over Maxine Vash gra now barring a
massive collapse does look like Fabiana
Carana will be grand chess tour Champion
but plenty to play for especially the
top three placings absolutely no uh big
fights ahead for that for sure butth
tell us about the roster of players for
this s field Cup oh it's good is good
and there you can see headlining the
vent it is none other than Al alira fua
with massive rating of
2796 Fabiana Caron in second place yan
pomi yan Kristoff Duda I mean the list
just goes on to lenia Dominguez there in
10th place leavon will be replacing
world champion ding Lin who couldn't
join us welcome welcome Leana and tell
us about the format for the svi C it's a
very good as well you know it's very
distinguished very classical 10 player
round robin the players will be playing
90 minutes for the first 40 moves then
there will be 30 minutes for the rest of
the game and of course the players do
get that 30 second increment or time
bonus as I like to call it from move one
and the best part no draw offers allowed
for these chaps but it is a standard
Point scoring system Fighting Chess
throughout tell us about the schedule
yes and uh the players will be playing
one round one game per day H take a note
they will be playing through
Thanksgiving and also Black Friday right
but there will be a rest day on Sunday
the November 26th and of course the
final day is on November the 30th and
there will be a day set aside for
playoffs if necessary thank you Joy and
Peter uh you got to break down the sinko
cup for us and tell us about previous
winners what just a great event it is
overall it is yeah the the absolute
Premier classical Tournament of the
world and before we dive in this year's
edition let's take a look at the history
of who won this tournament starting from
2013 and in 2013 a certain Magnus
Carlson wins it uh for the first time
when it's held in 2014 a historic event
happened in which uh Fabiano Carana as
you see on your screen there uh won
seven games in a row at some point and
abely blew the clear of the field with
that with that streak in 2015 Leon
aronian win
in 2016 we see a first occurrence of of
a player winning the singfield cup and
also the GCT with it but there will be
more of that uh coming later in 2017
Maxim Vash grav wins his first of two
singfield cups the only player to win
two outright in 2018 we see a massive
tie at the top with Fabiano Carana and
lanan being joined by Magnus Carlson
after he won a very very protracted
battle against Hikaru
Nakamura in 2019 ding Len who said is
missing this year has won both the
singfield cup and the
GCT no tournament in 2020 due to covid
in 2021 we see a return victory for
maxim MH graa Stella performance from
him and last year as most viewers
probably remember ala fua came to St
Louis and won absolutely everything
starting from the rap and Blitz and then
the singfield cup and with those two
victories the GCT as
well and on that note it is my pleasure
to introduce one more member of our
commentary team woman Grand Master
Nastasia carich good morning
n good morning Peter good morning yaser
and joy it's really nice to be back for
singfield cup I will be here not far
away from from the plane Hall conducting
interviews with players and I will be
also taking care of our social media
accounts so please don't forget to
follow grancher and St Louis chess club
accounts so let's take a look for
example what was happening yesterday we
had the technical meeting in the St
Louis in the Hall of Fame and uh during
the meeting we didn't have drawing of
flots procedure because we knew the the
pairings quite long ago but you can see
the technical director Tony reach and
then Chris berd who reminded players
about the regulations of the tournament
and after the technical meeting we had
also this nice dinner you can see
players chatting with each other we had
really nice and friendly atmosphere you
can see also Rex singfield himself um at
the table it was funny that Wesley so
had to sit just in front of his today's
um competitor ala fua it's a very
important game for both of them since
they're both fighting for the spot in
the candidates tournament and they're
competing whose rating will be higher at
certain points so it was a really lovely
evening yesterday only rich Robert was
missed because he was still traveling to
St Louis from bua 25 hours he had to
spend uh trying to reach the destination
and I saw him today in the morning he's
here everything is fine all players
should be in the planing venue right now
and it's time to get back to the studio
and see the action thank you Anastasia I
know from personal experience that jet
lag can be so brutal our my sympathies
for Richard go out but joy do the honors
tell our audience what they can expect
for the pairings for this round one I
can tell you a lot of Juicy matchups
already from round one Maxim Vash 2021
GCT champion who facing off against Le
aronian and Dominguez playing off
against his country mate Kon and Richard
rort who just came off that 24hour
Journey plays against yanomi now for
Anish giri this tournament is especially
important because he is the top of the
FED pircuit leaderboard and he will be
looking to maintain his standing there
with a good performance here he plays
Yan Kristof Duda and then this is
another huge matchup that Anastasia also
alluded to was so playing against alira
fuja these two are fighting it out for
that rating spot for the 2024 candidates
wonderful and there you see Richard kind
of a little tired there leaning on the
elbow I know that lean very well and as
you pointed out there's no draw offers
maybe he would want to make a draw offer
and go go to bed but no no no no but uh
there he is the man of the hour Fabiano
just having an absolutely absolutely
spectacular year what we're going to do
our best to bring to you some very
intriguing stats one I just throw this
right out at you laner Dominguez has
played in a number of sinkfield Cups and
ready for this undefeated never lost a
game in the sinkfield cup is won lanir
Dominguez impressive I wish I had that
statistic put that right and there you
see Wesley so and fuer getting ready to
do battle um Joy these players are going
to be very fighting hard for oh almost
the next two weeks what are they
fighting for they are fighting for this
and I wait for a second while as I pick
up my jaw off the ground I mean take a
look at that
$100,000 first prize as well as 12 or 13
Grand chestor points second place
65,000 thirdd place
$48,000 and all the way down to 10th
Place
10,500 not bad at all tournament there
is a for the grand chess tour there is a
pool of money for the players who finish
first second and third so those grand
chest T points very important uh mvl in
second place in the grand chest T point
he's looking to score as many as
possible as we see Chris bird getting
ready for final announcements before we
start day one and they are
underway and uh as we get ready for the
start let's go to our tournament leader
our grandchester leader and Fabiano uh
as again we saw him up against lineer
Dominguez and these two it looks like a
sicilian on board that's very
interesting Bobby's main defense has
been e
E5 and the an indication that we're
having an open Sicilian is he's in a
combative mood be he is certainly in a
fighting mood but these two also have
worked together lenia Dominguez was his
second perhaps they've worked out that
some openings are untouchable right uh
the first impressions uh Peter a little
bit of a surprise for you it is for me
uh Fab is not a well-renowned ner player
I would say and ler is actually a very
very uh established very dangerous
opponent against the N of he's had uh a
number of very heavily theoretical
battles against mvl in particular
including some games in St Louis um
entering very very uh topical
complicated sharp lines so it is an
interesting choice against laner
specifically but I think uh something
that you've alluded to uh guys may be in
play here because having worked together
for a number of years you perhaps feel
that you should be playing something
that you haven't looked at together
right and this might be one of those one
of those cases as far as what to expect
uh linear generally I think plays Bish
B3 here he is very well known as a
person who continues you know flying the
flag of the Old English English attack
lines and understands them and knows
them extremely well but he probably did
not expect the nether of today I would
say it wasn't maybe the top of the least
of things to expect from Fabi so this
perhaps explains the pause because many
of the uh lanar games against Maxim Vash
gra would feature them uh you know
blitzing out 22 exact and then thinking
move 23 3 minutes into the round right
so he's already spent about a minute
here which by his standards against the
nider on move six he normally doesn't
doesn't hesitate so he's trying to
figure out what it what uh B is
expecting of him and uh perhaps to where
to deviate yeah wonderful for that
interesting and we've been presented
with some we did get F3 by the way F2 F3
projections yeah yes some very
interesting facts actually
byan Ben Underwood and he says uh has
only ever opened E4 with white pieces at
the sinkfield cup but that makes sense
because he is mainly an E4 player right
Carana has uh played against an E4
opening just 12 times as black in the
sinkfield and guess what and once again
I'm very envious of this stat just lost
one game with once with black once out
of out of 12 that's that's pretty
impressive that's very very very
impressive wow
uh and I'm reeling yeah and when it
comes to their matchup history and
there's been two wins for Dominguez 16
draws and four wins for Fabiano Carana
wow thank you for that by the way F2 F3
why F3 and not Bishop E3 is there some
there's a very specific reason for that
because Bishop E3 uh allows Knight G4 in
simple terms you you you would want to
play F3 basically next move against most
black reply
but the main difference is Bishop B3
allows Knight G4 and then you can either
Retreat to C1 and kind of rethink your
options after black normally also
returns to F6 or you can enter uh the
variation starting from here with the
bishop running all the way to G3 exactly
which provokes H6 and G5 which is a
weakening of the the black kingside
structure but we've spent a lot of time
moving the same piece around so this is
a a starting position with a lot of
theory whereas F3 uh allows Queen B6
that's the major difference the one way
not to allow white to play Bishop B3
here is the move Queen B6 which used to
be quite topical I think Gary Kasparov
at some point played quite a lot of
Queen B6 positions here but these days I
think people uh tend to ignore it and we
we already seeing uh Fabi go for the
absolute main line so now this is just a
transposition into the Bish B3 lines
right that we alluded to this is just
back to absolutely Mainline Theory thank
you Peter for that and then we're with
that point in our round we don't want it
to go too late as we make our
predictions as to going to win the
tournament because you know you know you
get a winning position you might go with
the guy who wins the first round right
yeah the player but joy uh you're the
lady in the studio uh your picks who's
going to win the 2023 s yeah
well my my favorite is actually Fabiana
Caron but someone has already said that
they were going to take him so I'm going
to take G Anish Gary yeah he's very
motivated he is and I I've just been
very impressed by the way that he's been
playing so far I mean things haven't
entirely gone his way but I don't know I
believe in him okay Anish I'm going to
go with a two-time champion
mvl I think he was that close to winning
the rapid and Blitz what he needed to do
to win the St leou rapid and Blitz was
to win his final game against Fabby well
guess what he had the black pieces he
outplayed Fabby he got to a position
where he was in fact winning he made the
a a wrong move he put his rook in such a
way that his Rook got trapped Fabby uh
snatched a draw uh from a losing
position mvl was that close to winning
and I think uh he's ready to once again
uh do a hattick win his third cup your
your pick uh I before I announce my pick
I wanted to actually uh expand on that
story a little bit because on air we
didn't really understand what happened
there and then I spoke to mvl yesterday
and he expl maybe even the day before
yesterday he explained to me what
happened uh he made that move which
basically blundered the exchange right
and uh threw away the win and he took it
back we saw it on screen that The Rook
went back and then he put it on its way
anyway accepted the draw and the loss of
the the tournament win and we were kind
of wondering why he didn't put it on a
different square and he told me that he
realized he he felt he dropped the piece
he felt he lost control with the piece
so he could no longer make a different
move so as often you know gentleman
gentlemanly code of conduct you know he
basically called the foul on himself
exactly without involving the arbit and
put it back on it too so you know a very
very good show of sportsmanship there by
MBL in a very important game right uh so
that story was somewhat missed when we
were covering the last round of of the
rapid and Blitz as for my pick
I'm going to you
know SOS policy I'm I'm going to go I'm
going to continue picking Yan I think I
think Yan is a a very very good player
obviously having played the last two
World Championship matches uh he was at
some point a very serious contender in
the rapid and Blitz before having a bit
of a nightmare in the on the final day
but I feel like classical actually suits
him quite well these days he's extremely
well prepared he's quite motivated uh
wants to kind of set the record straight
so I think Yan will be my pick again and
I'm being told that Varian who's been
working so nicely uh behind the scenes
in studio he's picking Fabby as well he
had prepared for us uh Fab's year we're
going to have a Graphic for you on just
an absolutely stunning 2023 Fabby had
2018 when he became the Challenger for
the world championship but this 2023 is
extraordinary it's something special as
well in fact let's just take a look at
what he's
done I mean because Joy I mean look at
this I mean then this is also just some
of the grand chest tour you know Romania
first place 100,000 on classical events
Grand chest tour Croatia fourth place
World Cup third place that is the way
that he's qualified to the 2024
candidates exactly uh US champion as
well and he it was a signature event for
Fabby I mean the US Championship it was
very clear who was first and I was just
going to say you know barring Hikaru
Nakamura defeating him at critical
moments he would have also have been
Norway chess champion as well as in the
grand Swiss as well you know he was
racing into the lead playing a fantastic
chess so on the verge of some
spectacular Brilliance there absolutely
by the way just now that I while you
were talking Peter and you were telling
us about
nepa's kind of subpar performance on day
two of the Blitz
I forgot to add that in day two of the
blitz also MV had a subpar performance
because prior to that he was leading by
two points uh and it we thought oh it
would take an epic collapse for him not
Absol and uh we also heard a bunch of
player interviews after the the day one
of Blitz which all of our players in the
studio talking to Anastasia were saying
no we're only figh fighting for second
here first first is done and dust M will
never let go of this lead and then two
rounds into the second day he was caught
up by two people so it was it was quite
a stunning reversal he's had honestly a
bit of a nightmare on that day um
because we've been talking chitchatting
back and forth we get going to get
Anastasia's uh pick as well as to who
she thinks is going to win the
tournament uh just update us uh with the
lanir Fabby game because quite a number
of moves have been made since E5 AB the
big decision came the first big decision
of the game came here on move nine where
uh Fabby played H7 H5 which is something
that uh if you go back to Miguel nidor
himself perhaps so some of the earlier
Classics of the nid I don't take Gary
Kasparov uh and the the way nid has been
played up until maybe the mid 90s I
would say this would have been somewhat
Unthinkable because you're still you're
still expecting to Castle King side and
you are moving a pawn in front of your
king making it arguably much easier for
white to open that King side up
eventually but but these days it's
universally understood that stopping G2
G4 for quite a long while because
playing H3 doesn't threaten G4 anyway
and also allows H4 right completely
blocking the structure so what we're
doing by playing H5 is we're stopping
the very normal way of playing for white
here which would be BL play G4 play H4
play G5 drive away the knight from the
F6 Square which is a very important
Square controlling uh the square on
D5 but yes we will have to pay attention
to not getting made eventually on the
king side because 5 is not uh a very
useful move in many positions and to
this uh lar applied with Knight D5 uh
Knight takes D5 this is also an
interesting little subplot because I
think these days people have been mainly
going for these positions
although with the inclusion of P2 and
Bishop B7 uh that means that black will
not be able to play the plan with uh
there is a can I actually let's see if I
can work this out yeah I think I can
when the bishop is still on the starting
position there is often a plan of
playing G7 G6 and trying to trade this
bishop on E3 via the H6 Square having
already played Bishop E7 perhaps you're
less incentivized to enter these
structures so Knight D5 e D5 Bishop F5
Bishop B2 and an interesting move A6 A5
here which uh nods uh towards White very
often wanting to play Knight B3 A5
themselves uh this is a kind of an idea
that often is quite advantageous for
white because White's play now that we
are sort of giving up on giving mate on
the king side we'll be involving a rapid
expansion expansion on the queen side
and starting with Knight A5 is very very
often a useful kind of a jumping off
point for white to start launching their
pawns up the board so A5 getting rid of
that square for the White Knight now it
really can only go backwards for the
time being uh A4 played by lineer also
understandably stopping A5 A4 and now
black spends two temp provoking G2 G3
wow it's strange stuff right because you
know I I was brought up on classical
chess and you know I see ready black is
breaking a few rules conceding the
squares and again provoking some
weaknesses King safety is an issue but
um I mean it's a very dynamic position I
guess is modern day chess that's the
best way of putting it
H5 with A5 where's Black's King going to
where's Fabby going to put his King now
that you've proba goes King side
surprisingly because I don't think white
is going to Castle Queen side with the
bishop on F5 alive very often if you
want to Castle Queen side you will have
to play Bishop D3 and honestly apart
from understanding how important it is
to stop G4 I think people at some point
realize that the fact that you played H5
doesn't actually mean you will
immediately get mated if you Castle King
side So eventually it will be on G8
anyway the question is whether Fabby
does it quickly or he waits for white to
commit to uh something uh immediately
and by the way I was wondering about uh
White's KN on B3 and where it might go
one of the squares I was thinking Peter
it really belongs on is the C3 Square so
you got to kind of vacate E2 and right
away we see the move Bishop uh G Bishop
E2 to B5 check Peter are we still in
theory judging by the speed of fa's play
I would say very likely at least FIB
Theory specifically right I can give you
the answer to that one yes and uh it is
still in theory Bishop B5 check is is
still okay and here Bishop D7 came very
quickly by the way it did and here white
has played uh two games with Queen going
to E2 Queen has stepped one square
forward to d32 twice even Castle's
kingside has been played uh for why
Castle's kingside that's very logical
looking move as well huh okay well thank
you for that we've got five
gains in progress and uh L well Fai
certainly deserves our attention because
again his his career has just been so
outstanding um where would you like to
take us Peter uh let's start from the
top uh because there's a very sharp
position on the board in a game between
two old friends Maxim MRA playing White
against uh Leon or Onan which started
off as a pretty uh standard uh regoin
regoin is a major major opening these
days and top level tournaments most
players uh these days who play the D4 D5
and also the nimzo group of openings
will have included Ragin at some point
in their repertoire for sure Bishop G5
is the reply by mvl H6 Bishop H4 a very
fighting line and here black can do a
number of things including what uh
leevon has done which is just take on C4
and say I am now Pawn up what are you
going to do about it do something yeah
in particular with with the inclusion of
H6 and Bishop H4 it means that
uh if we do it
here um this is just a classic Vienna
right uh and white will be able to take
on F6 and take on C4 in case of H6 if we
start with H6 first and then we take on
C4 if you play E4 here you are
sacrificing a lot of material and it's
it's often these days playable to do
these things and you see people do these
types of sacrifices more and more but
here it feels like maybe we are giving
up a little bit too much uh which is why
uh uh mvl just went uh A3 oops sorry uh
A3 Bishop takes E3 and B takes E3 uh for
the time being just saying I'm not going
to bother trying to win this Pawn back
the threat I guess is uh e24 although
you still have to worry about G5 but the
idea is either to play E3 or to play E4
for the time being black plays C5 uh E3
is the choice by mvl I think which is
very easily understood because if you if
you want to be very ambitious I think
you run into Queen A5 then and queen
takes C3 is a massive massive threat
this doesn't really look very attractive
so E3 and here uh uh Leon played Queen
D5 that's the most ambitious move in the
position by far Peter it certainly is
but uh one of my favorite sayings is
that the secret ambition of a gamer is
to win back the pawn so immediately I'm
looking at Queen A4 check win back the
C4 Pawn three that s of relief and
Bishop D7 Bish D7 four wi back the pawn
but you've been win back the pawn but
you forc the trade of Queens yeah but I
have the bishop pair and is isn't that
something these days that Grandmasters
highly prize yes absolutely yes
absolutely and uh as as usual the engine
suggests that many things in life are
pretty much around equal and it says
even even playing something like this
with the idea of following it up with
Knight A5 this bishop very often will be
going to C6 eventually is not that bad
there is also the suggestion of maybe
even starting with CD4 CD4 and Knight C6
then the Knight could go Bishop C to the
D7 sorry bishop6 with the intention now
to uh develop this Knight on D7 and this
is also although this it kind of stopped
liking because of
knight5 um so very interesting but but
bike could also continue playing in
Gambit style and we have the head to
head yeah you can see that and their
classical seven wins seven losses these
players are close
one close to one another I mean nothing
can separate these two at all and uh
what is interesting though is that Maxim
I've traditionally Associated him as a
E4 player opening up with the King's
Pawn and now we see him try
D4 and and uh also uh an interesting
stat I have here is aronian only first
round loss was against hikara Nakamura
in
2013 that's 10 years ago the very first
uh tournament there was a quadrangular
and the idea was we were taking the two
top Americans in those days were hikaro
Nakamura and gotsky and we were
combining them against the two top
players of the world uh outside of the
United States and they were Magnus
Carlson and leavon aronian and in that
event in the singfield cup
Magnus signed the contract to play in
chenai we have some very nice historical
photos of Magnus uh signing the fiday
contract uh here in St Louis so it's
funny what you were just saying about
Maxine playing E4 leavon his most of his
career been playing D4 now leavon has
secretly been aspiring to learn how to
play E4 openings now you have the E4
player max secretly conspiring to learn
how to play D4 opening
and uh tell uh uh break this down for us
once again Queen A4
check okay I mean in fact I don't see
another move uh Peter if I don't play
Queen A4 check Bishop takes F6 I don't
find particularly compelling how am I
going to get that Bond back I think the
way to think about it
is the ideal setup if we're not playing
Queen A4 check would involve in some
order us playing the Knight to G2 and
then this Bishop will get to E2 and then
eventually to F3 right drawing arrows is
going to be tricky for today I will
eventually get the hang of it hopefully
got uh so if we are to continue in the
Gambit ve we are probably starting with
either 92 or Bish P2 the engine
currently prefers Bishop B2 actually is
seems to be suggesting it's a very
playable move uh because the pawn on C4
as long as black cannot comfortably play
b75 it continues being vulnerable to our
attacks so for us to just finish
development and eventually start
attacking the pawn on C4 is quite quite
sensible but we're being told that Queen
D5 is a novelty and then it's very
understandable that MBL is taking a
longish pause here for the first time in
the game because he needs to get his
bearings he knows he can win the pawn
back right away but that probably
simplifies the game and also will not be
a surprise for leevon so he is uh I
think currently weighing up just how
risky he feels uh not trying to win it
back immediately is for him thank you
Peter uh in the game between Richie
report and uh Yan I I see we've got
again one of these Russian defenses the
pet defense uh Yan plays it uh
incredibly
good I mean it seems like he's got a a
vest of armor on when he uh plays uh the
Russian and Peter break this game down
for us uh
uh the openings thus far this is a Yan
has not pioneered because it has become
popular prior to him playing it in the
world in world championship and and
afterwards as well but he is very much
Bishop the bishop D6 player uh and uh
after uh castles castles C4 and C6 uh
Richie goes for sort of the old favorite
and this actually brings me back to
something that we discussed in our in
our opening segment where uh we know
that he's traveled for 25 hours to to
get here here and we mentioned that he
probably wouldn't mind a draw today
frankly just to get some sleep uh but
it's unavailable due to no drawers no
drawers allowed right this line though I
think affords him one of the better
chances of of actually forcing a draw
because I think we're still actually
following my game against Alexander Gish
the candidate no no not not the
candidate it was in the European Club
cup where I think I started with G4 here
which is honestly a bit of a mistake and
after A6 I was honestly a bit lucky that
after Rook B7 Bishop takes G4 a h takes
G4 and queen C8 white has this Rook move
Rook B6 because the Rook is hanging this
kind of a temporary piece sacrifice here
with Bishop G4 is extremely strong we
cannot not take on G4 this bishop needs
to be removed off the board and now the
Rook is hanging and the pawn on G4 is
hanging with at least the perpetual and
if you go let's say all the way down you
are probably going to lose this game
because after King H1 for instance black
can do the usual thing of bringing the
queen on H3 and playing 9 G4 and the
threats of Bishop H2 as you can see the
engine already is suggesting the game is
gone right but very luckily for white
you can play Rook B6 and after Queen G4
King H1 the fact that the bishop is
hanging forces black to give this
Perpetual so this is already an option
for Rich and if you don't do that if you
play Bishop G5 I think there was a game
in one of the uh tournaments earlier
this year where it was probably in the
grand
uh in in in a global chess league if I'm
if I'm not mistaken where Yan very very
confidently
held uh this end game against Vish V
vishan and this end game was supposed to
be somewhat dangerous but Yan I think
started thinking about move
33 so he know indication he knows he
knows exactly what he's doing here and
uh so so Richie I think very consciously
has gone for a line where he's losing
chances up pretty much zip white is more
or less never going to lose any of these
positions but he has options of going
for what amounts to uh you know a very
very small winning chance but basically
just a position that will be uh
simplified and uh equalized by his
opponent I have it in my mind that in
the candidates tournament in Madrid
essentially uh Richie had to make a a
repetition in the game and he went on a
su side March and he essentially just
gave a full point to Jan and Yan went on
to become the Challenger Magnus as we
know uh Ste down and it was uh Yan
versus ding but that but
Richie got
ambitious you exactly the wrong
moment uh what was that what was that
game where Richie it was I remember
exactly what you're talking about but I
I I wouldn't be able to recall the
position it was from a Russian defense
as well I think so yeah yeah okay and A6
already played by Yan so Yan quite
clearly I think they they have this kind
of a mutual understanding that uh this
is what we're entering and yes maybe
Rich has a small idea how to improve on
vious play maybe ask a question
somewhere but I think uh here there is a
kind of a Meeting of Minds because Yan
round one he uh he didn't really finish
the rapid and Blitz that well and black
against a strong player I think you're
never that unhappy with defending
solidly and uh sort of getting the
tournament of a normal start exactly
yeah and for for Richie as well it's I
think it's an acceptable result today
right I I can see for Richard is
acceptable result you know he's come off
a 25h hour Journey he's played in the
European Team Championships there we can
see him on the camera but um but for Yan
he's he he came third in the rapid and
Blitz surely he wants to set the tone
for this event and perhaps ask more
questions from Richard by choosing
perhaps a more aggressive opening well
they are following that line where you
get into a bishops of opposite color uh
an extra Pawn maybe not the most
meaningful but as you were saying a two
result game Peter yeah absolutely but I
think if black doesn't know exactly what
to aim for you could even be in trouble
and uh uh if we are permitted to a
little bit of a diip dive here I think
specifically because of uh how
supposedly uh tricky this end game was
there was at some point a school of
thought which which said starting with
B6 is better because if if if white does
the same thing it is of course Very Much
preferable for black to have the
structure on the queen side on the
squares where they cannot be attacked by
the bishop on D3 and this is just
completely equal like there's no way
this can be ever be better for white but
uh as I said Yan has just basically
worked out how to make a draw in this
position position so uh yes if you're
imprecise yes if you perhaps just allow
white to stabilize and particularly if
you imagine this Pawn from C3 getting
all the way to C5 fixing fixing the7
without losing anything in the center
you could you could very much imagine
this going sideways for black but Yan
just knows yeah what's their head to
head uh
J well it seems take a look at this far
it's not quite seven losses 31 draws but
it is one win one loss A each uh a piece
and 10 draws between the pair of them
nothing separated them in a dozen games
as uh Richie at the board uh two more uh
games to take a a look at as we go
around thing I just wanted to mention
that we should highlight there is one
big trap on the board that white has to
take care of The Rook on D5 because as
Pete is highlighting it's undefended it
is UND defended and loose pieces do drop
off absolutely and before we leave this
game and probably return to it once once
it's concluded I just want to say
there's also a bit of an additional
needle there because uh rard was
famously ding Len second in the world
championship match and uh uh this always
you know changes your relationship with
a player a little bit when when he is
the one helping your opponent in one of
the most important events of your life
so there's been there's been some
interesting interview quotes since that
much I'm I'm not trying to you know
imply their enemies something but but
there's there's some additional needle
going on there I remember I was the
second to Victor kcho and His World
Championship matches and a world
championship match pardon me uh against
karpoff and then after that match I had
played against Anatoli kpu and I used
some Victor kchoi analysis against
against Anatoli and one and it was like
Victor was really happy with me because
it was sort of like uh you revealed our
work mhm but you got the result as well
so that was very very good sometimes you
reveal what you've uh pre prepped you
you know exactly what I'm talking about
because you of course were a Vladimir my
my record is not as Stellar as yours not
that great but I have seconded some
people in my life yeah nice um let's go
to your pick if you don't mind to Anish
uh versus Duda and by the way one of the
players that I
I wasn't un unsure of I was going to
pick Duda if not for mvl I just I really
thought that mvl played a great rapid
and Blitz and he's due uh Yan Kristoff
Duda has had a very nice uh 2023 as well
and he's he's very Fu and very ambitious
very very ambitious you know he has a
nickname polish Warrior and it's not for
nothing you know he goes into every game
wanting to win but you know he has
chosen the Berlin berin hasn't everybody
at this point in their career suddenly
Vladimir karnick has started a trend and
everybody got on the same uh fashion and
this of course is the Berlin ending
these days rookie won and uh you know
Bishop takes C6 to dodge the ending but
when they do get into the ending I don't
know I don't know Peter the ending
certainly to my mind has not brought
much uh success to the white players not
recently no and I want to say this is
kind of a sign of the maybe not exactly
the times but the we've uh we're no
longer playing the St Louis rapid and
Blitz because in the entirety of that
event which was 90 games of Blitz and
also 45 games of Rapid we had zero pure
barings I think wow I'm pretty sure we
had we had quite a lot of anti barlings
but we had I think zero pure berlins and
here we are in round one of the the
singfield cup and the Queens are off the
board and we are welcome to classical
chess absolutely yeah very very happy to
see this uh this old
friend A5 A4 this looks a bit
unconventional to my eyes I mean
everybody's been playing H5 H4 and
Bishop E7 and A5 A4 what what's this
wrinkle all about Peter I I am not sure
I feel like you know I pet you're my top
agent you know I
can't I can't really bow out here and
say I have I have no idea about any of
these positions because I was hired to
have an idea about these positions but
you know in as far as these things go
the Berlin is very very clearly top of
the list of things I profess to have no
knowledge about okay uh gaining space on
Queen side is always a good idea but I
don't think I've I've seen I'm sure A5
has been played but A5 followed by A4
immediately is is very new to me I'm not
entirely sure uh what this entails young
Shish also is not playing this quickly
which is a bit surprising because you
know having chosen the Berlin he must
have paid at least some attention to the
possibility of Anish sort of picking up
the gauntlet and actually going for the
for the end game and uh a 5 A4 would
imply to me that he is sort of driving
the action he is the one choosing the
position that they're playing but Anish
is also head on on the clock uh so all
of this is uh a tiny bit confusing to me
Bishop F 4way being told by by VAR is
rare black replies with H6 6 is always a
very useful move because you often want
to put this bishop on A6 and then not
not having to worry about Knight G5 is
useful also with the bishop on F4 there
will be some positions where G7 G5 is
not completely pointless it's a very
committal move you also obviously the
moment you play G5 uh the Knight gets J
yeah this this becomes this becomes the
issue but uh for now a good a good
waiting move and you have to you have to
wonder what what white is intending to
do here yeah
Joy what I was going to say because
isn't White's plan generally to expand
on the king side exactly use your
majority you want to play G4 and get it
going but uh you just black just rolls
with the punches and says okay you got
G4 so what what's next yeah and and big
question also for white is do you take
some action on the queen side as well I
mean do you let that a porn go one
square further to A3 I probably play A3
myself just to stop you know the
weakening over there on the other hand
um well Peter is3 a useful move I'm not
convinced because first of all first of
all we have to we have to sort of go to
go to the beginning the pawn landed on
A4 here right and Anish has already not
played a31 so I think he is perfectly
okay with the let's say he went B yeah
so I think this change of structure
doesn't doesn't bother him all that much
because this could be a problem if let's
say sometime in the future we end up
with an end game where black Black's
light Square survives white also
probably plays C2 C4 and then the second
Rank and perhaps some diagonal entrances
become available and the PA A2 could
become a Target but that's a very very
farfetched not maybe not farfetched but
it's some way into the future from from
now 50 yeah and and we for the time
being we're developing pieces we're
preparing to launch something in the
center on the king side where which is
where white normally would play
and also an additional layer to this is
I don't know if A2 A3 is that good
structurally because it also freezes our
quinide very much because we we we
probably will end up either with this
structure or let's say I don't know
let's make some moves just to make the
legal moves on the board eventually we
might even have to play C2 C3 because
the pawn C2 often gets hit let's say by
the bishop arriving on F5 and yes that
stops the advantage
but it also
absolutely hamstrings our potential
ideas on the queen side yes Queen side
is not where we're supposed to play but
preserving some flexibility I think is
the name of the game here uh so I I
wouldn't I wouldn't touch the a pawn for
now I would I would feel that uh black
really isn't threatening A3 strongly
enough for us to care about it deeply
it's good to know you have to fight the
instincts right to that porn I I wasn't
sure uh throw them up the bar G4 move
your knight go F4 go F5 uh put your
majority to work and finally uh our our
fifth and final game uh of the round uh
we're going to jump to the game between
Wesley so and Ali
Raza Ali Raza the defending Grand
chestor Champion as you said Peter he
came to St Louis a year ago he came he
saw he conquered he took all the marbles
and he went home as a champion it was
the most fantastic two weeks of his life
uh he's not going to repeat this year
but he's we know that he's in a fight to
try to get into the candidates again uh
talk about these two players well it's a
very as we've already established it's a
very important uh battle between them
because they appear to be in very direct
contention for the one rating spot
available ala currently with a massive
advant and uh seemingly I briefly
checked it because honestly it defied
belief so Yanka was absolutely correct
in telling me that it's just one rating
list and I flat out refus to believe her
because in in Years Gone by whenever
there was a rating spot on offer it
would be over a period of time a formula
yeah uh let's say a full calendar year
or perhaps less but never one list but
apparently it's just the January list
and they will not play classical chess
after the singfield cup so what happens
here
defines perhaps the future of that
rating spot and as you can see on your
screen there is a 25 Point difference
which will be very very difficult to
make up in one tournament but if you
were to make up the difference in one
tournament You Begin by beating your
direct position because it's plus it's
plus five points for you and minus five
points for your opponent and this is the
rating watch that we're discussing Joey
and uh there you can see that yeah okay
it's
2777 on on our screens but on this
screen you see that Ali Resa fuan has
dropped down to 2762 on the live ratings
and Anish giri moved up to
2754 and Wesley is there on
2752 and of course to remind everybody
that in a game that Wesley and Fu are
playing essentially if Wesley were to
win he would gain five rating points fua
would lose five rating points so it
would be a 10-point swing
equal footing instantly equal footing on
2757 is so yeah this becomes an even
more critical game and uh yeah I'm sure
Wesley is aware of all of that and is
taking this very very seriously as for
the opening you can see the kind of very
normal Queen's Gambit decline type
position once again it's too early to
call this a Queen's Gambit decline
because it can transpose to all kinds of
things we have seen Bishop before here
played in the MBL aronian game and that
s go in and here we get the thei
by Ala and after C takes D5 perhaps a
slight surprise from from Wesley because
C takes D4 these days the position that
they discuss seemingly adium is Queen
takes D4 e takes D5
E4 and in this position both knight6 and
specifically this position has been
discussed uh incessantly by the very
very top players over the last I don't
know five years let's say but with
Wesley playing the black side a lot of
those games too kind of known to be a
drawing line and a way to kind of kill
the attacking opportunities after D4 and
instead of that Wesley goes Knight takes
D4 and move six Knight takes D5 and
Bishop D2 which frankly doesn't really
look like it should should should uh
refuse the opening strategy of the of
the black player but it's a way to
perhaps make alz a play over the board
and ala chooses Bishop C5 here which is
a playable move but other other squares
were absolutely a way ailable for that
Bishop Knight B3 Bishop B6 uh Wesley
goes G3 and here you get the first
inkling of what kind of a game he is
trying to achieve here uh and with ala
basically being quite compliant we will
see it on the board castles Bishop G2
Knight C6 castles and here early res it
takes on
C3 and what we have on our screens here
is a position where it hasn't been a
Catlin but it looks very you know
Catalin in spirit white has a very very
nice Bishop on G2 dominating the the
long diagonal and black has a bishop on
C8 which has not very much to do right
this moment and this is why I'm I'm
actually kind of gratified by seeing the
first line I was very very interested in
the idea of playing e65 straight away W
okay we want to lengthen this diagonal
it looks like a pawn sacrifice because
Bishop takes C6 followed by Bishop takes
C5 is available but with the H3 Square
available for the bishop on C8 as you
can see the engine avoids the queen
trade for now and then we'll play Bishop
H3 and it instantly claims that there is
perfectly perfectly good enough
compensation for the pawn they would
argue maybe that uh White could be
interested in getting of the first but
then after rookie eight the pawn gets
one back you you you since the the F to
pawn is spinned you cannot play F4 you
have to drop the Queen the bishop back
black will take on E2 and with a pair of
Bishops yes the pawn six is a bit
vulnerable but with the pair of Bishops
he pretty much never lose this position
agreed and uh Apparently after the move
E5 uh it's it's a theoretical battle
four games have been tried uh I wouldn't
be that eager to capture the pawn in
this case but Peter uh if we if we were
to continue the ending with Well Middle
game Rook C1 here do you want to take on
d8 here or uh guess not let say just
after Rook C1 honestly with with black
I'd be very tempted to keep the queen
keep
the bishop proba comes out G4 which is
why I see on my screen that the engine
very often just goes E3 un seemingly
unprovoked just to make sure that Bishop
doesn't land on G4 with such power and
then we go Bishop B6 we probably want to
play uh F7 F6 at some point put one Rook
on d8 one Rook on C8 I don't really see
why we are supposed to be wors here with
black uh to be entirely honest okay so
after E5 which by the way has been
played in while we were while we were
discussing all of this Wesley needs to
be very concrete and it feels like in
the next five moves we will have a
conclusive uh evidence whether white is
better or not yeah I feel like Wesley
actually has to start making some
aggressive moves here actually you know
I'm trying to visualize the future and
seeing that maybe even Knight could jump
to C5 or maybe the a porn could start
lifting up the board and asking
questions right then uh for me the
Knight on B3 isn't game yeah I want to
put the Knight on C4 want to put the
Knight on D5 I love the Catalan Bishop
but at the same time this move E7 E5
also reinforces the D4 Square for black
so so I'm thinking E2
E3 you know I I love Rooks on open file
so Rook A1 to C1 was you know second
nature for me E2 E3 if I'm going to play
E2 E3 by the way I it does occur to me
that I have opened up the possibility of
Queen H5 so we do have a a line there
where maybe you do play Bishop E6 and I
do question whether or not you want to
play the move F7 F6 after Queen
H5 it it's weird uh will uh definitely
uh keep a an eye on this one as we're
getting and
wow
suddenly to the Future cuz I just versus
Yan and yeah that that one went uh that
went really fast to uh rook and Bishop
versus Rook this thisen no but this is
heavily reminiscent of of the uh Anan
Nishi game from Dubai I have a feeling
they might even still be following it
but maybe not maybe there was some kind
of a little little Quirk which deviated
from that game but that also is exactly
how that game went white collected the
entire Queen side but in response black
gets this EX extremely active Rook on D2
the pawns on A4 and C4 has disjointed
and weakened and will be attacked
there's also a very important motive of
trying to play Bishop C5 pinning white
to the protection of the F2 Pawn white
is currently two pawns up and the the
engine is giving straight zeros z z not
even 0.10 just just says completely
equaled you got nothing you got you got
nothing whatsoever and a good thing for
black is after let's say C5 Bishop takes
C5 and rookie to and this actually makes
makes sense from the white point because
at least solving the issue of uh second
this this hanging is useful I have a
sneaking suspicion even this is just the
level once once we' played Bishop A3
because with the normal structure on the
king side people sometimes win these end
games famously uh Jonathan Spielman beat
seski in the final round of the 94
Moscow Olympiad in a match which decided
the the bronze medal
but with a PA
F2 tied to it SP yes you can move
everything one square forward but then
once again this one this one will be
stuck and eventually once you move your
king to the other side I will pick it up
and then even if the a pawn costs me a
bishop by that point I will develop so
much counterplay on the other side of
the board that it's just I think
completely drawn yeah uh Peter I I'm
sorry I just have to say you're
terrifying me here with your discussion
of this position because I feel that
this might have been an ending and
probably is an ending that Yan has
prepared for and he knows that it's
triple zeros how 3023 how deep is the
preparation of the top Grand Masters
today have you ever done anything like
this where you went all the way into an
ending to a rook ending let's say once
or twice yes from opening to ending in
in specifically very very forcing
variations you occasionally get lines
where it's conceivable to uh to to to
get to move 30 even 35 as you see C5 on
your screen I wonder if Yan will take on
E2 because I have a feeling it's a very
comfortable draw but keeping the Rooks
on is also a draw because the Rook will
be very active and white has all of
these weaknesses on uh on the king side
but I think the easiest way here is just
a take but to I mean in reality though I
mean this this doesn't happen in 90% of
the game I mean this is just Elite no
that's what I'm saying it's
terrifying when you do get these moments
I think a lot of people do get put off
by that but no no trust me there will be
mistakes made people will
misremember and Rook E2 and okay the
Rooks do leave the board and we are
expecting napom to play Bishop A3 and
blockade the Aon that's very important
thing to note okay whilst this one
players are pedaling furiously to that
draw let's move to another game to uh
Dominguez against car
because that one is nowhere close to a
draw the players have done one of my
favorite things they've castled on
opposite size of the board and to my
eyes this position is wild great we left
it at Bishop B5 check Bishop F5 back to
D7 Queen E2 there was a number of moves
including Castle short but Queen E2
makes perfect sense I was kind of like
beating the table that the Knight on B3
needed a better pastures Queen E2 uh
vacates the D2 Square castles Knight D2
Bishop B5 Queen B5 all of these moves
look very logical I would say am I
reading right that Fabiano has barely
used any time on the clock on the
contrary he's gained time on the clock
he started with 90 minutes that is 1
hour 30 so he's gained pay attention to
that little fact and it's his opponent
lanir who has actually used all the time
between the two of them 30 minutes to
play King B1 Knight A6 and finally Fab
having his first stop no no he very
quickly uh retreated his his Queen to d8
defending the pawn on D6 jump and Peter
uh are we still on sacred hollowed
ground theoretically speaking pby
clearly knows what he's doing I'm pretty
sure this is not and has agreed a draw
between no draw offers but conspiring to
steer the the game into equal channels
uh Richie makes an easy draw sorry
please continue Peter yeah I I I I don't
have access to databases on on this
particular screen but I'd be shocked if
this was still following anything these
are these are logical moves and I think
Fabi clearly knows what he's doing where
is fing year he's down uh this is it's
actually even more because they get half
a minute for
increment made 22 moves so he spent 40
actually to get here he spent 40 to get
here against Fab who basically spent
sometime walking I would say uh Knight
A6 apparently is a novalty so even even
up up to here all all the way up to King
B1 this is still known so it's known to
Fabi but perhaps not as much to lineer
although lineer I think has been known
to even in positions he knows intimately
well to to spend some time double
checking triple checking making sure he
is not forgetting or is remembering
things exactly uh as for the objective
value of this position uh at first my
engine loved it for white and thought
you you play F4 you play Rook H1 you
create pressure against the black center
but now it the evaluation is uh dropping
into manageable uh manageable uh levels
F4 it suggests playing Knight C5
important to know that the B7 Pawn is
hanging but I think in most cases yeah
like you you have apparently already
lost in this position because after F5
followed by Knight C5 followed by Rook
B8 things start just completely
collapsing You' really only want to take
this Pawn if it wins you the game
because opening files like this in front
of your king just for one Pawn is not
great no so F4 it goes Knight C5 here in
this position perhaps it's slightly less
suicidal to take but it still hates it
uh because after Rook B4 black develops
a lot of uh a lot of play on The Queen
side once again so the engine after
Knight C5 goes Rook H E1
uh and in this position it eventually
realized black can go for uh this
structure
change after
which I think it's pretty clear that if
you give black some more time to
stabilize black will be better because
there's now protected passer in the
center the engine to my somewhat you
know this is my shocked face it actually
goes G3 G4 here HG and H3 makes sense
makes sense now it's on theable but
right yeah but maybe not your first
instinct but it does make perfect sense
because white needs to be extremely fast
here if you once again if you give black
time to play Rook C8 I don't know Queen
F6 double on the C file you're always
going to be picking black uh so this
appears playable and this also I think
gives us a kind of a sneak peek as to
what Fabby is intending Knight C5 is
going to be pretty much always his next
move because this is a gorgeous gorgeous
Knight Knight on e4 which dominates the
entire position needs to be tra Lena go
for opening lines immediately like for
instance well no no not that one I
wanted to go H4 first and then G4 next
comes yeah doesn't feel fast enough
right because you also have tactical
issues because if you play G3 G4 here
you aren't actually winning it back yeah
you're KN and yes you can play for some
kind of compensation just drop back to2
and you know claim that you've opened up
some files on on the king side and it
loses tonight takes say four but even
let's say if we look at this position oh
look this is actually this is completely
playable yeah so in in in spirit this is
a very understandable and maybe a good
decision but move by move my general
feeling is it's going to not be quick
enough yeah and uh well a lot of these
problems got hinged on white trading or
allowing the trade of knights right I
mean could we be seeing something like
for instance you prepare G4 and then
when the Knight comes to C5 and says
trade you say oh no no thank you very
much I will head back okay so you're
thinking Queen E2 Knight C5 Knight C3 is
C3 you know move the Knight back to C3
let the Knight do some defensive work
for a change uh unfortunately this this
starts very quickly actually this this
play uh and then it goes to B6 and then
it goes to B4 and then the queen comes
out by6 get that scoundrel away from the
position no no you can't about that no
absolutely
shockingly black is a lot closer to
launching something quite serious on the
queen side than it looks it looks like
all of these pieces are just about
managing to hold white at Bay but in
fact you give black a coup of Tempe here
and you might be feeling feeling quite
unsafe on as we know I'll take credit
where credit is due I am a bit of a pong
grubber I don't like playing Queen takes
B7 for those obvious reasons Rook D3
Knight C5 Knight C5 Rook C5 Rook Queen
B7 in this case cuz I have Rook D3 to B3
as a useful inter Mezo choose a square
choose a square a A6 it has to be A6
because A7 is a draw offer so we're not
really considering it as a winning
attempt
yeah seems like this is very very decent
and whilst this is a decent position for
black we are going to go over to
Anastasia who is there with a
guest yeah I have here yanish she with
me welcome Yan we haven't seen you for
all these days how did it go for you
first of all s Louis rapit and Blitz
event you were fighting till the very
end yeah I wasn't I wasn't doing great
um I mean yeah I have nothing to proud
of rapbit and biss I think even despite
this like hor starts in rapit I had all
the chances to you know
to to win it all in B but yeah also I
got
like I think I was a little bit too
careless in the first day like losing uh
last two games without U um a good
reason to do this to do so
so
yeah um I ended up like sharing first
place yeah but of course I'm I'm
disappointed uh yeah so also I was B I
felt you know a little bit unwell maybe
some cold uh the second day of brid so
yeah now I'm trying trying to to recover
yeah the what what do you think was The
crucial moment when you lost your
chances to fight for the victory in the
tournament which game was let's say the
most important for you well uh I think
it was very close till the very end yeah
but uh yeah
clearly I think uh losing to fuja who
played awfully that day but he only
played a good game against me and yeah
also I think it was a like a direct
encounter with Fabiano so I was a little
bit lucky to win the first game but yeah
the second game yeah uh I think I played
purly and um yeah uh you know it was a
little bit to late and I saw that
actually he's also fighting for some
places I thought it's like two horse
races they say like me and Maxim but
then okay I so like some some other guys
are also like taking
joining yeah yeah so now we are already
started the single cup time time flies
and today you played against Rich rort
uh the interesting fact is that rich was
traveling I think you know about it from
B he didn't come also for the technical
meeting yesterday did you try to take
have you thought about it to try to get
take advantage of the fact that Richie
just came from vwa and let's say maybe
not in the best shape well like maybe it
would be some uh some wise thing to do
but uh as for me I more focused on
myself uh so yeah it's still like the
recovery is like I know I'm
Midway um to recover like recovering
from the cold so I think it's uh it's a
question who was in WEA shape yeah I
guess I guess yeah it good of course he
could pick like a different line like to
make it more complex but I think he
pretty much repeated the game I had to
the game I played against vland this
year in um in Dubai mhm uh so was one of
my few good games that went but it was
more or less whole prep so yeah so until
which moment it was your preparation the
variant or well I think you played even
one move today to be honest to be honest
I think the vishi at this position I
might be mistaken but Bish should played
here Rook
E5 and it was like Rook A2 Rook E5 like
check King G2 Bishop B2 and yeah leads
pretty much to the same to the same
thing yeah same structure uh like
opposite color Bishops and um yeah we we
know it's it's not so eventful yeah I
understand so now just last question for
you now that the sful cup has started
who do you think will fight for the
first places in this tour for the top
especially now knowing the shape of the
players from St Louis rapid and blad
also okay we have some new players but
so what is what do you think about it I
think I will
good try that's a good on this really
optimistic note let me finish this
interview all the best of luck for you
Yan thank you and we go back to the
studio thank you Anastasia well another
guy in studio Peter also uh believes in
and nepo chances that's what we like to
hear yes yes a very optimistic uh note
there we saw Yan clearly suffering from
a cold as well very difficult to play
chess when you're feeling unwell uh for
sure uh we have one result uh first draw
of the SFI cup and later we're going to
be talking about round one results and
why they are so critical you'd be
surprised the number of decisive games
and whoever wins round one often times
goes on to win the event shock that was
a huge shock quite the
Revelation in the studio see Richie
report and nepo first to cross swords
first to make a draw we are reaching
that time of the broadcast when we do a
check-in with our friends at Q Boutique
and see what's on special offer
obviously you know we very we're very
generous and we do allow friends and
family to have 5% discounts but you're
going to be amazed what's coming up here
this year SFI cup can keep you warm for
years to come with this amazingly
comfortable jacket and it really is a a
comfy One features an embroidery 2023
sink pill Cup logo on the left breast
the St Louis chess club logo on the back
of the neck and the 2023 Grand chest Tor
logo on the right sleeve the jacket is
in stock in both men's and women's
Styles check out all your chess shopping
news need s pardon me at qbt
stl.com and for the holidays this is
unbelievable check this out 20% off uh
check that out I for all of the stuff
how generous Joy it is very generous and
it's the perfect gift for the chess
lover in your life absolutely go now to
cutique and check it out we'll see you
on the other side of this break as uh
coverage of the sville cup continues
don't go
[Music]
anywhere hello I'm women's Grand Master
Jan I will be creating content for Grand
chest store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the Ed educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships as well as high-profile
tournaments that attract the world's
best players become a member and enjoy
perks such as free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments and so much more
visit St Louis chess club.org to claim
your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an award
winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there
[Music]
is on welcome to St Louis welcome to
Gran Tour Part of your persona is
actually in social media and um have
really individual and humorous tweets
and what do you think I mean what impact
social media uh have on chess players
life these days and um is it something
what you like to do or you're trying to
build in a way self brand through social
media yeah it's I no longer like
tweeting for a very long time but I
um yeah have sort of built
um some sort of a you know small chest
uh brand on online and um I I keep the
the fire burning there I think it's U
it's been very helpful for me um I've
gotten a lot of more opportunities um
because of that and uh a lot of fans and
a lot of support
so you know I'm not like hikaro who uh
who is really going all out on uh on
streaming I I wasn't able to to do that
um but I still try to yeah have some
online presentence but uh last year I
been focusing much more on the you know
the classical chess on the world
championship cycle and it's been very um
very exciting for me so I I hope to
finish this um season on on a high yeah
and speaking about the world
championship cycle and in general what's
happening on the top I know you always
have an opinion so can you just let's
say speak a little bit about what's
happening right now last year with
Magnus who withdrew from the cycle with
dink who actually been absent for for a
long time with who still actually keeps
playing quite well so like what's
happening right now what are the new
trends let's say no like as you
mentioned definitely very exciting times
in a sense I mean you've got Magnus who
sort of um trying
to um not not not retire but uh at the
same
time yeah he's he's you know withdrawn
from certain things like the classical
uh World Championship cycle and also
he's choosing his events um
in a different way than usual and of
course yeah of course the fact that Ding
after his world championship title was
wasn't playing much that's also
something unusual and of course that
hikaro is uh uh at the very top after
all these years because he's been there
for for many many years and um it's only
after he sort of stopped playing
professionally as he he says it that he
you know that his reason to so this High
although of course hiari he had his
Peaks as well before I think he won VI
tournament he was 2800 at a given moment
um but still he sort of experiencing a
second Peak right now and that that's
quite remarkable and we of course have
also a lot of youngsters um that are up
and coming but uh it isn't it isn't as
easy as as uh you would expect and many
of the youngsters they have uh risen and
but then they have sort of Fallen back a
bit as you could see with lza his rating
went all the way to 2800 then dropped a
bit and you also have like player like
GES or AB satov um they've sort of went
very quickly and entered the top 10 even
AB satov also went very high but then uh
at some point um they weren't able to
keep up the momentum because of course
it's really hard to to stay at the top
so uh for a while they they dro the
rating a little bit back but I guess
they will keep um moving forward but
more than like two steps forwards one
step back kind of um kind of style so
yeah very exciting times uh and still
the players of Fabiano's generation are
doing very well Fabi himself of and wly
occasionally Maxim slamming the door
also very loudly in certain events
so I think a good time to be to be a
chess fan and uh uh also the the world
championship cycle is looking very
exciting so I'm I'm quite curious uh to
see also you got the you know the online
chess movement thing going so definitely
a special time to to be a chess fan
where do you see yourself on in this
circuit I yeah well you know I'm I'm a
social media influencer
doing uh doing my thing no I'm I'm doing
uh I'm happy with uh uh yeah with with
what I'm doing I'm um I find playing CH
very rewarding and uh very challenging
as well and
uh to an extent the fact that you know
I'm not as great as uh let's say Carlson
or some other players like it's it makes
it more fun for me to um to try because
you know I things don't come easy for me
and when I do have a good result I
really enjoy it thoroughly uh it's
um you know when it's so hard for you to
to achieve then whenever something good
happens I think the reward that you feel
is also higher
um I have some experience playing like
much weer tournaments um sometimes let's
say I played that championships uh when
the lineup was not very strong um and
then there a different kind of event
because you are under a lot of pressure
you have to you have to win usually you
do win but of course it doesn't feel as
rewarding so there's not much to gain so
in in my chess career uh it's very
different because I have a lot to gain
always I not um you know world number
one or anything like that so there's a
lot of challenges for me and whenever I
achieve something local um I'm just
really really happy yeah I think it's a
really good moment to finish this
interview and wish you good luck in the
tournament thank
[Music]
you
hello I'm women's Grand Master V tojan I
will be creating content for Grand chest
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Lewis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
education hello I'm women's grandmas Bri
to janova I will take you behind the
scenes of the gr chest St follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the
play
hello and uh we are back with the
coverage of round one of the sink fi cup
and we are joined in the studio by a
very special guest Tony Rich the
technical director of the grand chest
tour and Tony welcome to the show thanks
Joy it's good to be
here time in this studio we brought in
the big dog for the commentary Tony that
we needed to up our game the
hard-hitting analysis that's that's why
you're the pointy guy over there I think
he needs to go up
right welcome Tony nice to have you in
studio it's good to be here tell us
about what's coming up sure I'm excited
about the 2024 Grand chest tour season
uh teaser we will be back in all of our
great countries and cities that we were
in in 2023 for Repeat Performance okay
the grand chest tour will kick off in
May next year just like it did in 2023
and we'll start our events in Poland
we'll continue on from there to Grand
chest tour uh in Romania that would be
the grand chest tour classic we continue
from there to Grand chest tour Croatia
and then finally we finish up in St
Louis with the St Louis rapid and Blitz
and sinkfield cup in August so it's
defitely a very different uh time
schedule obviously we're in November
right now and uh the events have all got
squeezed together that's right yeah so
we're moving back to the the summertime
for singfield cup um you know it's
interesting the the grand chest circuit
being a a series of tournaments it's
great whenever we can get this all in in
just a few months three four five months
something like that the players enjoy
the fact that they can go from the first
event to the last event it's
hard-hitting it's fast they know what
the standings are and they know what's
at stake so bringing everything back to
the summer I think is really great for
the grand chest tour yeah and obviously
this is our tour but there's so many
other tournaments including the club has
so many events the classics and
everything else Tony you you I don't
know how you guys do it frankly
sometimes you do too much we direct
about 25 major events a year and major
events are ones that are fed rated
tournaments that where Norms are
possible right so this would be the five
national championships the singfield cup
and St Louis rapid and Blitz the Kiren
cup four classic tournaments a year for
those very strong Collegiate players and
the folks breaking through to that 2700
level Norm tournaments for players just
trying to become Grand Masters it works
out to on average about once a month a
little more than that we'll have one or
two tournaments at the same time right
well you guys are hosting and then right
across the street you've got all the
world stuff that's happening at the
World Chess Hall of Fame from the
exhibits to the music and everything you
just it it's constant we're lucky to
have such great Partners at the hall of
fame you know the exhibits over there I
always came I came from a Chess World
right so I was the chess player and
never the chess historian the chess
artist I didn't appreciate that aspect
of the game and the Hall of Fame really
has changed that for me it it shows you
the cultural impact chess has made in
pop culture in commercials in comic
books even right all the way through
Fine Art you know chess and how it's
used in in media chess and how it's used
in commercials in television the Hall of
Fame teaches you why you should play
chess exactly yeah and what was exciting
schedule for 2024 which one are you
personally looking forward to seeing um
whichever one Magnus plays and I'll say
it's always exciting whenever we get the
highest rated player competing in our
events right Tony I have to say for me
personally speaking when you have
audience and spectator
it's so much more attractive personally
now I understand why we went to the
model of you know keeping the hall
without the spectators because as you
see on screen at the World Chess Hall of
Fame uh this the the space is
comfortable for the players you add 100
Spectators and be a little bit packed
uh don't you miss the spectators though
absolutely oser I am one of those
Spectators who loves to sit there and
watch them play their games I want to
see the Nuance of a player and in the
pressure they feel or maybe the
confidence that they feel me too so I
can tell you that the remodel of the
chess club is underway now okay uh we've
been on a delay unfortunately for the
past year or so construction has been
halted absolutely all of these hurdles
uh should finally be coming to an end we
have a closing date set in early
December and in theory that means we can
start driving nails into the walls
shortly after that so the hope is that
once construction starts it'll take 12
months for completion okay so in 2024
the events for the St Louis chess club
will be at the World Chess Hall of Fame
as you saw earlier um but we look
forward to 2025 bringing everybody back
to the club Tony thank you so much for
being in studio thank you for telling us
and I can't wait to have the spectators
uh allowed in again thank you so much my
pleasure thank you so much for joining
us and uh tell us about the results thus
far uh
well we are just a few hours in and we
already have a result between Richard
report andachi the players pved out very
peacefully but there is still action to
play for full on fire on the board in
other games and let's go and uh a look
at some of the exciting moments yeah
Peter what caught your attention let's
start with our one Sicilian for the day
it's always a a nice thing to to have a
full-blown nidorf on on the board and
this is our did you say full-blown Caro
Khan on the board yeah he did that is AB
that is absolutely thank you than you
very much I appreciate the
support so this is the game between
lener Dominguez and Fabiano Coran to
very strong players who have also worked
together which may have influenced the
choice of opening today that's not what
I wanted uh and we left it here yes and
we actually got the line that we
discussed quite seriously all the way up
to F5 and E4 the night trade followed by
Fabi establishing this beach head on on
the E4 square and laner thought for
quite a bit I'm sure he considered the
move G3 G4 here which in in in pretty
much every single position here will be
quite thematic trying to immediately
open up the black king on G8 but he
started by a more conservative option he
went Queen E2 attacking the pawn on H5
if black plays G6 here I'm pretty sure
now we go g4a now we go G4 but black
will not play G6 in fact the pawn on H5
uh is very likely to be ignored at least
for the time being you can also remind
white that there's a counterpart of it
on the A4 square if it gets protected by
B3 you can continue being a bit of a
nuisance here uh attacking the pawn on
C2 perhaps the bishop the queen will
slide over to the B6 square and as you
can see black continues solving all of
these tactically uh problems of the H5
Pawn hanging tactically even though
current
uh my engine is saying we have now
secured the quein side we are completely
fine it's time to go in on the other
side of the board and seems to like G4 H
G4 and H3 here uh black of course along
the way will have other options perhaps
instead of Queen B6 Queen C5 is stronger
actually I don't know why I chose B6 C5
is just obviously a superior Square
attacking the pawn on D5 as well and not
stopping our own breaks with B7 B5
because after G4 we could have a very
comical situation where white goes G4
and black says okay Anything You Can Do
I Can Do Better uh so very very sharp
position in which Fabby is finally below
the starting time right might actually
be thinking for himself for the first
time in the game who knows we we we
never know with extremely well prepared
players such as uh he is but a very
exciting uh potentially very sharp uh
heavy piece ending on midle as you were
saying you love the positions with the
Kings on
opposite so you can go for exactly so
this I was going to ask a question to
Peter and yourself I mean there you
mentioned that white needed to secure
the queen side and that's just a
question of approach I mean could white
just go let's go for it immediately
Let's uh not play The Rook C1 because I
find that that's quite a subtle move so
I like this B3 idea so we're not giving
up on A4 here right no no we don't no no
no no okay you're talking to two porn
Grabbers fair enough we're going to have
we do about the C2 uh unit okay cuz B5
is coming so that's actually an
important idea right so you can't just
lash out but can we do the C4 can we do
the C4 just to okay if I can if you can
go F5 and H5 to lock down the king side
let me go A4 C4 to lock down I think
we'll start by playing yeah Rook takes
C4 is actually a threat now because
we're overloading the queen on E2 so I
guess you have to spend a temp on King
A2 and then let's say we go Rook C7
and and you want to start going here
finally I feel secure enough on the
queen side that I can go Hog
Wild and guess what anything you I can
better look it looks completely closed
here it does and every time we continue
past this point where we think it's
going to be a boring symmetrical
position then it it gets completely
exploded on both flanks um the more I
look at what the engine thinks is best
play in these types of positions the
more excited I am what the future might
have in store for us because it seems
like it's actually extremely logical for
for white to go for this break and very
often the best reply black will have is
just to play B7 B5 sacrificing it in two
directions even wow just to get some
files open on the queen side so I think
this is a very very exciting game is
definitely exciting and I just wanted
one final thing and uh if I'm I'm going
to whisper this if one does not defend
the pawn on A3
we taking while we playing G4 we we're
going to go G4 let's go fullon
aggression apparently apparently I'm
already in a lot of trouble I should
have taken with the other pawn it says
oh really yeah okay okay but now we
traded the the the G for car with with
the with H3 yeah why why why disturb the
balance you know you found a nice idea
there's a disturbance in the forest
exactly
you're winning my heart with your Star
Wars references uh oh well this seems to
be as you can see uh on on our bar here
it seems completely playable for white
and once again the more we look at these
things the more my my impression is that
it's often black who has to be extremely
precise because if you if you take it
you know a little bit less aair and uh
and make one in accurate move somewhere
in response to these potential breaks
the engine starts screaming that you've
made a massive mistake and you're now in
a lot of trouble so Fabby will now that
and I think with him thinking for about
10 minutes on this move we have to
assume that queen2 perhaps wasn't on
file uh he will have to be very very
precise here yeah at the price of an era
very yeah costly indeed uh when we left
it mvl my choice uh for the tournament
uh he had gotten the two Bishops he went
Queen a for sha he won back the Gambit
at pwn as you said you know it's the
secret of all gambers they they actually
don't like being a pawn down well he
recovered his Pawn Knight C6 Peter was
also mentioning there was ideas of
Bishop uh to C6 and bringing the Knight
to D7 but uh leavon had a very concrete
plan and that was to meet Rook B1 with
Knight A5 what are you going to do with
the queen well there was a trade Queen
takes Knight takes no more Bishop takes
F6 six for you give me the pawn on C3 no
that is one you cannot have C uh 3 C4 at
first I I I was pretty darn sure the
Knight was actually going to jump into
C3 just to tickle the rook and ask The
Rook where would you like to go and then
maybe you would drop it back to A4
Knight E7 on the board Bishop D3 we've
caught up with the players Peter take it
away uh I like what JY said I got the
two Bishops what's wrong for perhaps a
move for oh yeah and and I think this is
why 97 my reaction was exactly the same
as yours they got to this position and I
thought the Knight will go to C3 it will
get it will get kicked away it will land
on A4 which is not not a bad square at
all and this is kind of very normal it
seems like Black's counterplay here will
be on the queen side so why not put most
of your pieces on the queen side but
Knight D7 is a very very concrete move
because we're just telling white we are
playing knight5 the H4 needs to be
secured somehow in order for this bishop
not to be traded off immediately perhaps
you needed to play Bishop G3 but then
black can play Rook C8 or even maybe C
takes D4 followed by Rook C8 both of
those appear to be playable and knight5
will continue being something you need
to pay attention to instead uh Maxim
just went Bishop D3 and the engine
suggests it's perfectly fine to do this
because yes you are ruining your
structure a little bit by moving the the
pawn from E6 to F5 double double pawns
on the f file but C4 is quite vulnerable
here and after
castles I would be trying to play
something like Rook C8 but the engine to
my honestly slight surprise goes CD4
Knight D4
B6 I would be very worried I will
blunder C4 C5 here somewhere and then my
pieces will lack coordination but I
guess the point currently is that if you
play it immediately the Knight doesn't
really have a particular Stellar Square
to jump to and if you try preparing it
with Rook fc1 it suggests we can stop
with by Knight B7 and if you imagine in
let's say we make some kind of an
indifferent move and this Knight lands
on C5 which is completely fine for black
right after just watching Richie raor
and napo's Bishops of opposite color
this game has got nothing going for this
ending interestingly while we were
talking uh leevon played Rook C8 and
which is also which is also completely
logical move the pawn on C4 Remains the
target so why not start with this but I
thought five immediately was entirely
playable and is it possible to ever
unbalance porn structure like for
instance I know this is I'm committing a
few cardinal sins here but I'm just
thinking ideas of
D5 with the exchange on
E7 I think first of all it it will very
often fail tactically through this
intermet of take C4 but even if it
didn't even if it didn't I don't think
this end game is all that great for for
for white because uh some position like
this with Rook h E8 and then C4 B5 it
feels like the King on D6 it's the king
is supposed to be a poor blocker but in
in this particular position it seems to
be quite comfortable on D6 and uh it
just looks nice for black while you guys
have been conversing uh wesly so and uh
Ali Raza it looks to my eyes that
they're just about ready to make a draw
and look at that our second opposite
Bishops opposite color Bishops yeah yeah
and there you go
uh trading um more or less uh Peter with
without too much guess workor it's like
the
players well prepared went from opening
to endgame and and ala handled this uh
very nicely he he did have some problems
to solve in the opening but he played
the6 C5 at the time where it was
required and then Wesley uh having gone
through uh Wesley decisions after uh
Bishop takes c35 it looked like once the
movie 5 landed on the board he uh kind
of assessed the situation and thought I
don't believe I'm any better here at all
so why not uh just sort of simplify and
see if I can find some kind of a
position with a very very little
practical advantage on zero risk and
three-time repetition has been didn't
really achieve that yeah it has been
claimed as we saw the Arbiter Chris bird
approving the claim of the two players
and we had second draw sorry uh about
that we were just watching it in real
time you were taking us back uh to the
opening there Peter and you were saying
with the move uh yeah as we see the
players uh filling in their score
sheets so two reasonably quiet uh draws
so far uh uh players seem very intent on
undermining the very carefully prepared
stats that we have for you uh we will
still we will still show them to you but
and there and there you have it on your
screen just now yeah yeah you can see
the players have agreed to draw and yeah
we were compiling the well our Staci Ben
Underwood was compiling the stats
exactly and it came up with a rather
shocking statistic the most it really
really cool so the idea was we wanted to
do some stats like the sporting world
and show you what happens when things
you know get out of control and this was
the thing that was really shocking to us
Joie the importance of round one exactly
round one is historically the most
decisive round with the
48.8% of the games and and I would not
have guessed that I know I was guessing
the penultimate round n start jangling
and uh also something seven out of the
nine singfield cups featured winners who
won their first round and that's
ridiculous I would have never guessed
that guessed that right so round one is
the most decisive rounds that's why we
featured two draws to get us
started and mvl and leavon have uh won
the most uh first rounds uh I'm about to
be on screen
Mom I'm about to be Onre why why do they
always win the first round Peter because
they're good at chess and I will be on
screen for a different reason you've
been victimized hopefully there I am I
played three Phil cops in in my entire
life and I lost the first round in all
three of
them boy but Peter I tell you you were
like 14 at the time how old were you
still 14 I don't know what she's talking
about uh you're always number one in my
book I don't care if you're tired with
Wesley I you're number one in my yes on
that particular count I think I think I
should take Preston CU I only played
three and he played a bunch so nice uh
is it surprising for you in your vast
tournament experience as well as my own
that you win the first round you win the
tournament not really no I never equated
it that way yeah I wouldn't be confident
in predicting that such a high number of
players actually went on to win because
obviously there there will be cases
where more than one person won the first
round only one of them can win the
tournament but right but for me I can
say from personal experience starting
well is an unbelievably important and
winning an early game just sets sets
tone for for the whole tournament and
helps enormously honestly doesn't really
shock me at all uh the number like the
the the percentage seven out of nine is
maybe higher than I would have guessed
but um STS to reason like really
starting well just makes you feel so
much better about the the tournament
going forward that no I think it's
logical yeah Fair two quick two short
draws where's the action Peter uh still
the Sicilian but let's take a look at
the other two for for the time being as
fa is considering his options after
queen2 uh we spoke about the mvl onion
game so let's take a look at our Berlin
which is a question we were debating was
answered rather conclusively by Anish
giri here who after H6 thought for a
while and actually started playing on
the queen side himself not only not
stopping A3 but activ actively
encouraging A3 to which younga said no
such thing I like my pawns on the on the
L squares yeah I like I like having the
tension uh in the position there on the
queen side then Anish finally did
something on the other side of the board
and here uh Bishop B4 was the choice of
Yang Shish seemingly very normal would
be to drop back I wonder if he didn't
like the fact that after KN D4 his
extended structure on the queen side is
a little bit vulnerable you normally
would like to play Knight C6 but you at
least have to calculate Knight take C6
now with the idea of from d8 M after
Bishop B7 many things are hanging but it
seems like it works out for white after
takes B5 so the idea of Bishop B4 I
suppose is to provoke Knight E4 right
and then eventually you have to play
knight7 the KN on F5 has no other
squares but now we have the square on D5
to look forward to can can you also
start asking questions to the bishop on
B4 exactly that I mean you put your
Bishop on B4 but is it so well placed
there I've got A3 and maybe I can I can
hide it I can force it into hibernation
or something you can definitely drive it
to B6 but honestly on B6 it's not that
locked down if you could also threaten
it with C4 C5 that would be a very very
uh good thing for white to achieve but
C4 will always be met by uh black
snapping it off if you don't mind me
continuing Bishop E3 for just a moment I
would like to encourage you to capture
on E3 then I have the C5 Square as a
permanent yeah out I would I would agree
with you wholeheartedly if not the fact
that we already played G4 if this Pawn
was on G2 I would suggest maybe wear
borderline winning with white but but
it's already on G4 and you immediately
get counter get a hit with H6 H5 and
it's not going to be that easy to
stabilize the engine in fact starts with
Knight F2 and then who's going to be on
C5 we won right good point wait one
second you do have that plan in your
pocket okay so first of all you should
secure the king side and maybe go King
G2 yeah King G2 is to step up with and
then
G and then now I really want your Bishop
E3 idea I'm listening to you and I'm I
swear you're you're sounding just like
Grandmaster pal Beno first you secure
the king side then you take your outpost
on the queen side because that's not
running away and he would say secure the
king's side first go but I'm thinking I
I perhaps took too many measures to
secure the king side so now I think the
king can step up to G3 and now you can
drop back Bishop
E3 after Bishop B3 uh this is actually
stronger than the previous version
because uh Yanka is correctly
identifying that now King we will we
will have the move King G3 here
protecting our King side and leaving our
knight uh poised poised to go to uh C5
but the engine sadly doesn't feel like
this is so bad never
mind yeah it says that you won my heart
with yes you have this absolutely
gorgeous Knight on C5 but there is coun
to playay against uh against the white
king side but for now let's go to
Anastasia in the
studio and I have a special guest I have
ala f with us who just finished his draw
against Wesley um his game against
Wesley so in a draw and ala welcome back
to the studio I think you missed only
one day with us but actually I have no
idea what do you feel after the first
event World r i mean sorry St Louis
rapid and blit tournament um how did it
go for you the last day and what are
your emotions after yeah it was a good
start the last day but I didn't didn't
play really good I actually was very
close to get Take the Lead but I lost
two crucial games against Fabiano and
Maxim so that was the end the summary of
the tournament so I finished fifth it
was not really what I wanted of course
but um it's it was decent and now I'm
more focusing on the classical and of
course yes now we have single cup and
let's say you were the winner of the
previous one uh you had two days to
recover after the first event so how do
you feel what did you do during those
days yeah um I mainly wanted to switch
to classical mod my brain and because we
play how you do it it's not easy I think
but uh I think we played a good game
today and um it was important game also
for you because I lost to bestle in
Romania first game with white even so so
I had to be careful and I chose the very
solid opening so it was a I think decent
game yeah I think it this game was was
also important because you you are still
fighting for the spot in the candidates
tournament and it's all about the rating
as well so I'm sure you didn't want to
give some rating points to Wesley today
so let's see what happened yes how did
you manage to equalize I think so
comfortably yeah he chose the very solid
line of course also because he it's
first game and there's no need to take
so much risk and he is a very
fashionable line now and he choose
Bishop D2 I have some games here even
with black and I think this is the best
line there's not so much thing to talk
about I think here after E5 I
comfortably equalize because if he takes
the pawn it's always compensation here I
think even Bishop A6 and um you have two
Bishops yes yeah he has Pawn for two
Bishops but his King is always weak and
he has trouble to defend the E2 Pawn so
if he goes for instance Rook e one
rookie um I think even Queen D1 takes
Rook e a eight Bishop D4 and Bishop E2
just so he he tried to he was thinking
he was taking a lot his time here and I
think Tred to even bail out because if I
take my put my pieces out go as in the
game Bish show E6 F6 maybe I could I
cannot never be better but he just
forced the draw here with Bishop C6 and
Knight A5 and I always could go for the
opposite bishop and this is always the
draw so King F1 and yeah he Chang it
wasn't very clean games Yes actually yes
it was a exactly very clean like grandm
game uh do you think if you were in the
place of Wesley playing with white
pieces would you try to take more risk
considering the situation yeah prob
maybe he was surprised with my C5
opening Choice um I I play all kind of
moves here so maybe he didn't spend so
much time yes maybe he didn't prepare
for so I would not say that he wanted to
make draw today but it was just how the
game went so MH uh you said that you
really needed to switch to this
classical games and um let's say how
important is it do you mean that
sometimes you can make just quick moves
and it can completely change the
situation like Blitz sometimes you have
to just take your time to make sure and
but when you play a lot of Blitz and
Rapid games it's not easy to switch so
so what do you speak to yourself like or
do you put your hands you know somewhere
don't make a move
always it's a mental thing and they have
to but these guys are very good at
switching yeah this this for sure I
heard that you were in the Hall of Fame
yesterday and you bought some something
in the shop tell us a little bit about
this experience yeah it was um first I
mean we were we are always going from
the Hall of Fame to the playing H but
there's never time to see everything but
it's very interesting there's everything
written about the Fisher FK match and
and the shop is pretty cool I never been
to chess shop like this oh yes okay yeah
because they have many cool pieces
actually uh some even very expensive but
there is always affordable also but
there is some very cool expensive pieces
you can see also did they have already
some Black Friday discounts I I didn't
see it but hopefully next time there
will be yes okay 20% off this is what is
happening right now not bad not bad for
for our viewers also don't get to come
by and check the the shop of the vess
Hall of Fame yes maybe yaser or Yanka
have some questions uh to Ala uh no
questions for us just uh get focused and
uh well uh good good luck in the
tournament actually good luck in the
rest of your games Ali
Resa and with that I just wanted to turn
back actually to the game of un take a
look at this oh I apologize
all of these great stats for the
decisive games and there you can see you
have to remember sing F cup you're not
allowed to offer a draw okay so breaking
down the graph basically what the number
one says is in first rounds yes
48.8% in the history of the singfield
Cups have been decisive and then 39% for
round two and the least decisive rounds
were the ones that we agreed on the
penultimate in the I I was shocked by
this statistic I have to say because you
know like I thought you know the nerves
start jangling people need to be winning
by this point rest days and those things
exactly people start getting tired but
absolutely no the statistics do not
absolutely support that view instead
everything counts round one pet weigh in
on this is this uh surprising for you
that let's say the very last round game
cuz we know what those last round games
seem really mean and how how much effort
is put in so you're not too surprised by
a 26% decisive result for the last game
but are you surprised by the first yeah
I was slightly poo pooing your idea that
the seven out of nine statistic was
surprising this one is to to my eyes I'm
I'm shocked that it's almost 50% in
round one I can sort of see people being
fresh and playing fcing chess but still
so far above everything else and also 39
for round two does suggest that you
mentioned res days imagine how many res
days you have before the
tournament so maybe this is this is just
a very simple explanation people
people before the turn well actually
rest is a little bit annoying right
because they break the Rhythm the
routine and I looked forward to them I
really really did usually I was on jet
lag hours so I don't know well that may
be but early on we did see Anastasia
with alira fuja this time she is with
with Wesley so who is here to share his
thoughts with
us indeed I have Wesley so here with me
Wesley welcome finally we see you during
the interviews I didn't have chance to
talk to you before uh how was your
tournament rapid and Blitz before um it
it was shaky but but still finished not
so
bad you can call it that not so bad well
than thanks for having me uh first of
all the rapid and blit
it didn't start well and uh by the time
I started playing better tournament the
tournament was finished so uh yeah the
first day didn't go well I think my game
against Li if I made him during the
first game maybe things would have been
different like we were repeating
moves um but it just it just happened so
fast MH things happened so fast games
happened so fast there was no time to
recover I think you have to start in
good shape at the very beginning but uh
still it was a fun turn
I'm glad I participated yeah and then
you had like two days to recover
recharge your batteries and now we're in
the first round of sfold singfield cup
and how how did it go for you today this
important game also against ala yeah
didn't really lead anywhere much like I
thought I was slightly better out of the
opening but uh like here I had some
options but probably it was just equal
for the most part like I think 5 is very
accurate like I was going to play E3 but
then realize after Queen E7 probably
also not not much for white like he can
go F6 Bishop E6 MH so it's a very stale
position uh did you consider Bishop C6
and take taking this Pawn Yeah said
Bishop A6 right no he was kind of um he
thought that this position is still fine
for black but I mean did you have you
ever even consider it yeah I bit worried
about Queen G 5 the idea Rook d8 then I
have to move my Bishop somewhere I guess
Bishop F4 Bishop C but Bishop C3 is
probably not good because of Bishop H3
mhm I am and then I can't play Bishop D4
because of Rook d8 so meanwhile if I go
b f here then you can just go here H5 or
G6 I'm not sure I thought the bishop on
B6 very well placed mhm he also thought
to play Bishop A6 I mean according to
like immediately and trying to get this
Pawn back according to the engines it's
yeah I guess it equalizes too mhm but uh
I thought Queen G5 also doesn't like
black has more than enough compensation
so uh you decided not to go for this
line yes yeah after Queen G5 like I
thought my knight on B3 is misplaced and
then the bishop on B6 is very well
placed okay like maybe Queen E6 like
Queen H5 and then Bishop H3 is coming m
King's a bit unsafe mhm can become
unpleasant yes Bishops black always has
compensation like uh obviously modern
chess in order to win games I think well
a you need
to need your opponent to make mistakes
or B you get a good position out of the
opening and today I just didn't get too
much like I was expecting Bishop E7 on
move seven maybe but maybe bishop C5 is
also very accurate and Bishop
B6 and uh like let's say if you go here
probably also very easy to hold for
black after Bishop D7 followed by Bishop
C6
so yeah I don't know uh obviously need
stronger open stronger ideas with white
in the opening but what was your mood
and intentions before the game um
especially thinking about the fact that
you are fighting for the spot in the
candidates and you know
um if you win this game you could get
many points um rating points especially
yeah that's true yeah but my idea was
just to show up and play play a good
game and
uh uh you know I might not be the most
ambitious of player like I guess if he
car he would try super hard but uh it is
what it is you know I mean if I
qualified for the cand I'm totally
perfectly fine yeah but but maybe not
other people but for me
for me I'm fine but but you're still
fighting okay this game was not deciding
everything but I mean it could have
helped you a little bit yeah the thing
is things didn't work out for me well in
many tournaments this year and uh it's
uh right now I'm trying to repair repair
it but uh uh there's not much time left
but um yeah I'm very happy if I can play
a good game that's my first goal that's
also not such an easy job to thank you
so much Wesley and all the best of luck
for you in the next rounds thank you so
much yeah hopefully I can play better
thank you Anastasia thank you uh Wesley
uh Peter something's in the water and
we're saying Bishops of opp Opposite
color in a number of games and we almost
had had another one in this one after
Bishop before Anish actually spent quite
a lot of time on a decision here and
it's interesting sequence because what
he did was I love very understandable
but I thought something else has
happened but now I see that he actually
has gone for the line that I thought
Bishop D2 seems a bit counterintuitive
dropping the bishop back we just
developed it to F4 but it has a very
direct explanation because now with this
bishop on D2 counter counterposing the
the bishop on B4 you have this tactical
shot a very kind of a typical tactical
shot the bishop is hanging but more
importantly the pawn on C7 is hanging
trying to trade the Bishops first and
then take the Knight would immediately
lose the Knight takes C7 and white
collects everything so black has to take
Bishop takes B4 and it seems like we
made a lot of progress here with white
we Pawn up the bishop is on a very nice
diagonal here if black could Castle they
could no longer Castle but they can't
Castle anyway so this is maybe less of a
concern but after Knight C6 which has
been quite quickly played by Young Shuda
we get to a point where whatever we
choose to do here with white black will
play H6 H5 once again imagine the same
position with a Pawn on G2 instead of G4
white probably is line winning right but
because of the existence of H6 H5 as a
source of counterplay the Knight which
used to be on F5 and had very few
squares is actually very well positioned
on C6 it covers a lot of squares on the
D file it makes sure that Knight D4 can
be safely diffused by simply trading
these Knights and now we take on G4 if H
takes G4 he already have to worry about
Bishop B7 very very annoying threat of
Rook H1 coming in you will have to play
F3 and start giving material back so
somewhat surprisingly at least at first
to my eyes this appears to be completely
fine for black despite being upon down
and white having uh the move currently
there's just no good way to meet uh H6
H5 which is coming more or less next
move against whatever we choose I'm
going to have to cancel myself out of my
own organization because I'm a pawn
grubber I love the move Bishop D2 but I
didn't like the follow-up Peter that
Anish made which was Knight takes B5 yes
I wanted the play the move Knight E4 cuz
we were extoling the virtues of the C5
square and you know we plant a knight on
C5 why didn't he do this I'm not sure I
I think maybe he over I think the way
to describe it and it will sound
extremely stupid because maybe it is but
I know it's happened to me you you see a
position where you can win a pawn in
like two moves or one move or or you
have or you have a different opportunity
which feels like maybe it's stronger but
there is nothing particularly wrong with
the move that wins a pawn and you say to
yourself if I don't do it and my move
comes to nothing I will feel extremely
stupid because there was this pollen
offer why am I not winning it right but
frankly this just looks a bit more
promising than than the other one you
still have to work out what to do
against H5 right and if the suggestion
as it seems to be is to play G4 G5 in
this position which I'm currently
reading on my screen then maybe we can
excuse Anish for not playing it because
I
think I would need to think for I don't
know half an hour here and go through
all the rest of the options and somehow
refute them outright before I even
consider the move G I would be jumping
at Knight G5 as well right some some
Knight to G5 or Knight C5 or something
but apparently G5 is the best move here
and if it is then yes I I can see why
this hasn't been played because I don't
think uh it's a very human decision wow
but as things as things stand uh I think
uh young Shish has re reasons to be uh
quite satisfied with how uh things are
coming out pams and Bishops of opposite
College OV it's worked for neppo will it
work for uh Duda yeah it looks that way
I mean I really love the idea of going
Bishop B7 you
know1 idea Rook H um Fab's gone into the
tank when we talk about lanir going into
a tank uh we really uh do uh understand
that lanir is one of those players who
gets into time trouble and it's not
surprising for him to go to be the first
to go into a 30-minute thing when I
think about Faby going into a tank
that's very uncommon minutes razor sharp
though because yes you know we were
extoling the virtues of going Queen to
D7 but you need to back that up with a
lot of calculation because we were
looking at moves immediately challenging
yeah with G4 exploding open the center
and if you don't have a good answer to
that that's it you're busted that's it
uh at Peter remind our viewers who may
be joining us late what is uh what did
Fabby spend 40 minutes considering what
was going through his he he played more
or less instantly up until uh he played
e54 and after the linear dropped this
queen back to E2 attacking the pawn H5
this is where the pause came and I'm
painfully reminded of perhaps an
apocryphal but of kind of a very
well-known story which maybe yaser you
can even corroborate because you are
even closer to that time period than I
am uh there's a story about one of the
pitori memorials in which uh the Widow
of pittori came to one of the rounds and
she she she watched the player think for
like 45 minutes and then play Queen D2
E2 right and she turned to her neighbor
and quite loudly said he thought for so
long and made such a short
move so there we have it yeah he he f
for 35 minutes and then moved the piece
one square what is this right and uh
remember
uh I have
read this of Emanuel lasker's wife
coming into the playing Hall sitting
down in the front row making her
comfortable and manual thought for like
60 minutes and played H2 H3 in a
position where he was considering
sacrifices and she immediately just got
off the
tournament out of the T h31 move 60
Minutes kind you kind of expect to move
with more FL right right and why is the
move Queen D7
uh cost so much time as we it's just
that you have to be extremely precise
and I'm sure the move occurs to Black
because H5 is hanging and you want to
either defend it or create counter
threats you can't just ignore the fact
that the pawn in front of your king is
hanging right uh and the major point in
this position is uh black really doesn't
want to play G7 G6 uh we've been
discussing this before going on the
first break that White's idea in pretty
much every single position here is to go
for this break and you have to be
prepared for it in some shape or form
and queen D7 apart from attacking the
pawn on G4 as we have seen in some
positions it also has the added benefit
of giving you the option of taking with
the F Pawn because if the Rook takes on
e4 your Rooks are now there are squares
available to the Rooks which wouldn't
have been available to them if the queen
was still back on d8 so you can play
Rook f8 here you also have squares like
such as F5 here for the queen so Queen
D7 is a useful all round move and also
we are trying to provoke B3 okay after
which we will continue creating small
problems for white trying to defend
against Queen takes H5 by tactical means
and eventually a very very similar break
on the other side of the board to to the
G3 G3 G4 break for white B7 B5 will
become a topic in many many positions
here in fact to continue right there if
you don't mind B3 Queen C7 we looked at
C4 earlier uh Queen B6 yeah at tickling
The Rook on E3 can't take on H5 King A2
we've got everything secure yeah because
there was a threat of Rook takes C4 that
as well let's let's show this because
it's a very beautiful combination here
you can take on C4 using the fact that
the B3 Pawn is pinned and we are
overloading the queen queen has to
depart from E2 and now we just pick up
this rook and we're completely winning
suddenly so King A2 for the time being
the H5 Pawn is still not hanging because
The Rook on H3 thinging so we go Rook C7
now we go G4 yeah takes H3 and now this
is where the counter blow I take on G4
B5 occurred and my head started swimming
I thought oh my gosh now I'm in a world
of real calculation Joy yeah either that
but I do have one Golden Rule to
navigate this type of position and that
is change Queens trade Queens trade
Queens that's it so here like if you're
in trouble with white you just go Queen
to D2 don't think about it too hard and
then you might your
engine I don't know the Golden Rule
doesn't work every single time but's out
of 10 that's good that's good yeah in
fact in fact because B5 is already on
the board there's really no way back you
have to enter something like the first
line continues Rook D2 Rook C1 white has
to play Rook B2 here because let's show
this this is very beautiful if GF this
is mate in three yes takes I saw that
the queen H3 and and the mate comes down
and it comes down the board with mate uh
so you actually have to invest a Tempo
in Rook B2 like goes let's say Rook G1
creating a crushing threat of Rook C8 C1
you have to stop it and the game
continues as as usual very dispiriting
it still says zeros here and Yanka will
be very pleased with the fact that after
Rook C5 we do play Queen
D2
Basics are extremely
solid I very very solid foundation there
and this is apparently a force draw of
some sort I'm you you you you have to
you have to just either laugh or cry
whenever you see zeros in a position
like this uh just the current position
because it was it's not a line we've
been looking at but you know you always
for me I look at the forcing moves first
so the most forcing moves are check the
second most forcing moves are captured
so what would go on in my mind is Queen
takes H5 Queen takes A4 you're hitting
C2 I'm hitting on F5 no I go Rook B3
Rook B3 or Rook C1 which one do you
prefer cuz Rook B3 Rook C2 you have to
calculate I'm not sure you will like
like let's show this on the board
actually because it's instructive right
we're luring the king although you do
have Rook takes B7 apparently which is
still fine I thought black would be
better but has a nice threat of Queen to
fiden two and very interestingly BL just
says I will defend defend against that
and you have no more important threats
if you play Queen G6 here I have I have
Rook C7 because now you the Queen the
queen is no longer on H5 so the D1 Rook
is on PR so this is the rabbit hole I
would Chase my tail down I would be
calculating all of the captures captures
captures first and we didn't go here
takes Rook C1 Rook C1 and the engine
occupies a good square with the queen if
this Rook drops down I assume we're just
taking on
after Rook C1 it doesn't take on D5 it
includes one more move here attacking
stuff on the queen side trying to
provoke C3 if it does provoke C3 finally
it takes and then once again Yanka I
told
you out of 10 dentist dentists who get
this position recommend you trade Queens
exactly I always use plumbers but yeah
eight out of 10 nice uh great stuff
thank you Peter for that wow uh by the
way uh one tank uh great thing for uh
Fabby mvl also went into a bit of a tank
in his game against leavon Aron and
let's just jump into that game for a
moment because it they got the memo yeah
a little bit of the opposite color
Bishop ex take a look the bishop on H4
right Bishop D7 color Bishops when we
left it I don't even think it was the
move B6 I think c yeah cuss is already
for of yours B6 and I think you you were
saying you could go Knight F5 right away
but uh he he delayed a move takes takes
D5 not too much going on here Bishop's
of opposite colors this feels
perfectly I I mean to my eyes I I I
don't even think that this is a problem
I the Knight can quickly and easily re
reroute itself there will be a bishop on
G3 eventually so I don't know how how
comfortable we are with a KN on D6 but
I'll have also King on E7 I is true
could you be at some point very fancy I
just saw a nice idea okay it's um it's
for black it's just basically to give up
a porn and go f for for to get to get to
give up a porn did you hear me stut
because I didn't really want to
say I wanted you I want to make sure I
heard that right F5 F4 okay so the idea
is uh E4 and whoops you want to take a
pie yeah I want to take a piece and I
also wanted to lock out your Bishop okay
and so I fall for it I did take and then
you're saying my Bishop gets locked out
as you said you could put a bishop on F5
and maybe a Pawn on F6 and you can say
haha you're a pawn up your Bishop is
terrible exactly I like it well it's
it's it's perhaps uh not working right
now but because there is a rookie one
but I understand but I do I mean I think
that that's uh a type of a positional
Pawn sacrifice that I would like to play
as black personally yeah maybe F6 and
you were still in business and by the
way I think F6 leavon is on the board
maybe just prepping your idea uh
Joie uh of playing F5 F4 he's played F7
F6 uh game position uh Peter jump in on
uh this nice idea I like it yeah what
one thing I wanted to say is I've been
extoling the virtues of playing Knight
F5 pretty much ever since the night went
back to S but having the uh the
allseeing eye here in front of me I have
to say the idea of starting with F6
because I think we we pretty much always
have Knight F5 I don't think white is
ever going to play E34 and allow Tak D4
so the idea of playing F6 it also has a
very nice advantage of denying Knight E5
forever then we can go on King F7 then
perhaps we can even spend a Tempo on
rook hd8 and then if we want we can
pretty much always steal cash in cash in
our chips with engine engine was
suggesting this is extremely playable
not that it dislikes this end game very
much but it does suggest that white is a
touch better here after Bishop G G3 I'm
guessing the idea here if I am King F7
yeah if I am to construct a scenario in
which white is better I think it would
be something like 92 you make some kind
of a weird move Y and I get shockingly
actually no this is it says this is
equal I'm wondering where where the
progress is because ideas of F3 and E4
seem very very slow and I don't know
what they achieve even if they do happen
right uh my thought was maybe white is
better if you can imagine getting the
the knights off the board and then
pushing the a pawn all the way to A5 but
I guess the issue there is that the
bishop just lands on A4 and yes that's
what I wanted say and black asks white
exactly how are you planning to play a 3
A4 in this game Bishop of as a easy so I
I think I think this is entirely
playable it's just that uh the engine
was suggesting that F6 perhaps was
slightly more flexible and allowed you
more freedom of what to aim for but uh
what Leon is doing is is perfectly fine
as far as as far as I can tell Bishop G3
on the board King F7 is playable as you
were saying I don't really see much
wrong with the idea of playing let's say
King E7 and bringing over this is also
uh okay you can also play G5 uh ivanka's
idea of looking the bishop out I thought
maybe Works a bit better with the bishop
already on G3 let's say I don't know
let's make a move right something like
uh like this although the bishop will
actually get out wire F2 or H4 so I'm
not sure if I'm sold in general the idea
of looking it out appeals to me very
much but I I suspect it might not be
fast enough you can try with
H5 oh yeah that that would be that would
be a better way include H5 H5 H4 and now
we go now we go for this yeah this is
this is a much much better version yeah
good spot win cap of long so it it feels
like black might even still have uh
various ways of playing it all of which
appear to be uh fine but it's it's a a
non-standard structure and I suspect a
somewhat sharp end game potentially by
the way I'm just looking at your monitor
there and I think I'm seeing lanir
captured on H5 this for a very if you
don't mind jumping back to that for just
a moment Peter we're we we're prepping
for a break here but uh this looks like
it like some serious action is in store
for us here yeah and uh hang on a second
this hasn't been played this hasn't been
played uh so and the good thing uh about
your opponent thinking for 35 minutes is
that uh in the position where Fab is
spent all this time on the Move Queen D7
the year was also very obviously hard
hard at work trying to figure out what
to expect and trying to figure out a
reply to it because by his standards
Queen takes H5 came basically instantly
ler very much likes to think in
complicated positions and in my very
short time because I I saw that as we
were discussing the mvl game uh in my
very short time of checking it feels
like Queen B5 here right might actually
be the the one good solution there could
be others but I tried that's not in I
tried a logical move like Queen
and it says you're already in a lot of
trouble after Rook G2 because F5 is
hanging and G3 G4 is coming and this
setup with the Rooks on E3 and E is
extremely solid so you need to have some
contact uh with the F5 Pawn some ability
for also for the queen to get back and
very importantly also we are basically
protecting the F5 Pawn indirectly by
creating the idea of Queen F1 check to
to to demonstrate if white actually
takes we go Queen F1 Queen C4 and
obviously there is a draw available if
you drop back Rook B3 loses a rook and
the other other the only other move is
B3 after which black plays Queen B4 very
importantly wins one more Tempo and
threatens A5 A4 just in time which is
going to be M if it's if it's allowed
with nothing happening on the other side
of the board white still has perpetuals
yeah but the queen E6 check King f8 I
think Peter yes you don't go to I don't
know if yeah I guess g G4 and H3 M yeah
so you have to play we have to play King
f8 right but this appears to be uh
holding fine because of just how strong
the threat of A5 A4 is it trumps most
other things yes white can repeat but it
seems like there is nothing better even
even this position where we trade one
attacker off and there's also Queen
takes D6 with check so white is a pawn
up but once again A5 A4 is just such a
massive threat everywhere that white is
pretty much obliged to take a Perpetual
sooner rather than later thank you Peter
as we go to break uh we just want to
remind everybody of the results uh Joy
do the honors they've been well fought
grandm games they have been but two
hours in we do have two draws between
Richard raport and npal Masashi and a
draw between wesle so and Ali Resa fua
both players actually both games were
played perfectly that's what we get when
we play Perfect chess but still very
much a fight in the remaining three
games which uh brings us to well we have
a World Chess Hall of Fame we have what
is called the jingle bar up on the third
floor check this out uh it's it's really
a party room the the actual uh Hall
where the players are playing uh lots of
parties get host we call it the jingle
bar and check out uh the World Chess
Hall of fame. org to understand what I'm
talking about you sold me already Yes I
me just look at the biscuit look at the
party hot hot apple cider with cream
it's good stuff and as we go on break
yeah as we go on into a break will
Anastasia had an interview with Maxine
vov so enjoy this in the
[Music]
break
Maxim welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to Grand chour what what do you
think about the in general the State of
Affairs in the Chess World you know with
uh dingly ran absent with Magnus who
like lost some points lately with Hikaru
who show quite good result I mean in
general what is your opinion what's
happening now is someone who is inside
of all
this a lot is
changing uh these days um ESP especially
the level of preparation of every top
player but even the players uh one uh I
mean one circle behind like from 2650
let's say to 27 20 uh everyone's been
the opening preparation has improved
drastically because of computers so that
means the difference in level is
starting the Gap is reducing a bit
especially in classical I think in Rapid
and blads there still uh
like quite some difference um between
some
players and
um yeah you has been showing spectacular
results um for the past two years
um well done to him of course it doesn't
change the fact that Magnus has been
absolutely dominant for the past uh 12
13 years maybe in classical is less
dominant this year but I wouldn't say
that uh uh that is a trend and that uh
and that it will uh keep on forever and
I and for instance this year the most
impressive player I think has been
Fabiano because he showed the same
performance basically as iar but over
many more
events uh so Fabiano has been doing
great and you know I mean in general I
would call him the second player in the
world for the past 10 years uh there's
no doubt in my mind
um as for at least in classical chess of
course in Rapid and B it's another story
uh and as for ding U well he won this
world championship match uh I think he
was dominated throughout but he found
some great resources and then played
extremely well in the tie breaks uh
since then I guess he's been trying to
recover um because physically the much
um I mean Magnus has spoke spoken about
it so D also has sort of spoken about it
it's tough it takes t on you uh I do
expect to to see him back in 2024 and
you know I mean it's always been a great
player so again I I expect him to come
back at full
strength now you mentioned that many
young players many players from the 650
to 750 I mean are getting uh up uh do
you think someone else in the nearest
Future will cross
2,800 we not probably it might happen at
some point of course uh I didn't even
mention that there were so many like the
generation of course from 1990 and let's
say to
1994 uh with uh closing with Anish has
been absolutely
dominant um then the generation from 95
to 2000 I mean there's been some great
players of course there's Richard
there's uh Duda and some others but uh
it has failed to leave you know to the
expectations compared to to this 1990
and of course now we're seeing the new
generation coming let's say from 2002 to
20067 and I mean they have a great
prodiges great uh absolutely great
players uh especially from India but not
only from usbekistan as well and so
on so yeah I mean those guys will uh
likely fight for top spots in the next
few years do you think somebody can
replace Magnus on the first place on
top it will happen inevitably So like um
you know but for now I wouldn't even
count out
um um players from uh from our
generation to to keep fighting for the
next few years um then of course there's
Ali RZA who has had a few tough
tournaments lately but is still the only
one of this generation who is already
established as a top player and will
prove this worse in this uh you know uh
huge um tournaments like singfield cup
and so on so you know I mean I still
expect ala to do great as well yeah and
just last question coming back to grest
try to name like three players from
Young Generation who might participate
soon in GCT and will be full tour
players yeah year well I
mean it's very possible um I mean hard
to say but I do expect which one but I
do expect someone from India so like GES
or p uh or B I don't know if they'll be
playing already next year but I mean in
the next few years that's certainly
almost to guarantees there's of course
ABD satov and then from the even younger
players you have uh
COV uh was up uncoming and I mean you
have many others you have Vincent K also
is uh on the version of 2730 I think so
yeah that's quite huge yeah we have many
good flers that's for sure yes thank you
so much Maxim for this interview and all
the best of luck for you in both events
yeah thank
[Music]
you
hello I'm women's Grand Master V janova
I will be creating content for grandest
store follow us on social media and
catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championship as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello and welcome back to our
coverage of round one of the sink field
cup and uh just to refresh your memories
let's take a look at today's results so
far so we are 2 hours into the start of
play and you can see that we actually
have a third result there it was a draw
between Anish giri and
yang in the break and another result the
theme of the three draws have been
Bishops G I mean what Something In The
Water there I'm not quite sure what it
is uh Peter uh Anish and Duda they
had well actually let's go to Anastasia
who is actually there with yanish of
Duda and Yan Kristoff can explain to us
what exactly happened
lovely yes exactly let's ask Yan what
happened in this game Yanik Welcome to
our studio welcome to singfield cup it
was the first round um of the new event
for you it's first time you're playing
here how did it feel to play in the Hall
of Fame today yes hello um oh it was
quite nice I mean it was relatively easy
game so um I'm quite content with it uh
because I mean of course playing G is
very difficult you can play basically
anything and um I also kind of um I mean
of course I expected E4 and there were
roet but um still you know I didn't
consider it to be like a top priority I
mean to check and
was kind of uh because I'm not really a
buring player you know I I mean I've
played it like a couple of times I mean
in recent years but in general I mean
especially in the end game like you know
uh actually you know in some events it's
forbidden already to play this end game
you know they say no but no but the end
game can get quite interesting I think
uh I mean of course engines are showing
like zeros everywhere but um yeah in
general you know when uh humans do play
it's I mean can get tricky so I played
this A5 I think I I've had it only three
times actually with black and in all of
the games I played A5 and I mean the
idea is you know just to play you know
something um maybe let's explored and
and you know just just to get a game
yeah of course I mean like H5 and um
other setups with King on C8 for example
are I mean fine for black yeah I mean
everything is kind of good but yeah but
here I mean I was kind kind of confused
because um I mean I mean I I couldn't
because there are many ideas for black
uh for example I remember but I think it
was after Bishop F4 but I couldn't quite
recall that is this bishop B4 idea and
after Knight D4 for example Bishop B6 I
mean C3 A3 doesn't really matter Bishop
D5 yeah but after Rook D1 I um I kind of
forgot what to do I mean because after
Bishop B before I fought Knight E2 now
it's uh it's perhaps better version for
white you know because I don't have I
don't I I don't get to play this bishop
B6 Bishop D5 okay so I play A4 and here
I mean I mean I mean Al he could have
played like something else bop4 but it's
and H6 um this was the moment you
decided to start the attack on the king
side
or yeah no I mean I it's kind of the
waiting game by by now because I would
love to play Bishop V6 but um I didn't
really want to allow you know this uh
Knight G5 move I see okay so H6 H6 is
kind of prophylactic and but also maybe
one day you know I will play G5 or but
it's mostly against Knight G5 I guess so
B free it's very principal you know just
uh you know harassing my Pawn on A4 B5
it's also kind of typical after this A5
A4 but it's also a bit risky for me
becomes yeah yeah this C5 score also you
know
not Rosy at all yeah but here after G4
Bishop B4
um yeah actually my opponent
underestimated this uh this idea that
was played in the game um maybe he
thought that Bishop D2 and Knight B5 is
uh like he's just winning a pawn yeah
yeah no no he yeah he he was for sure
but um yeah perhaps um here's something
else um like I don't know 94
97 okay guys we check we check quickly
with the engine uh I mean with Anish so
I know I guess D4 is to move I didn't
really you know expect
it the thing with C3 is I guess I can
play D5 that's that's it's important
after A3 also yeah so um I mean this
bishop D2 looked very reasonable because
I didn't like this
position uh although it's still playable
for black Apparently after F6 I mean I I
was reluctant to do that yeah I mean
it's just the game yeah and of course
White is you know playing for free
because even if he drops the PA E6 which
is you know hard to imagine but still if
he does kind of draw so yeah so this
Knight D7 is very concrete uh I mean
it's very con concrete once he takes on
B5 because uh yeah now I just want to
play H5 and um yeah basically trade you
know as many pawns as possible and here
uh I mean Knight H2 was the move uh for
him but I thought
in general I know I have very good
compensation here I mean after some AG
Bishop B7 or whatever but I wanted to
play before you know to have this Rook
A5 idea and Haring the pawn on E5 and
yeah and if she tries to protect it I
don't know with some moves like F4 yeah
I mean still uh some Rook A5 I guess
maybe G5 in the proper moment you know
it it should Fizz out I think surely so
after I don't know Bishop F2 let's say
Tak takes G5 I guess I guess it's okay
for black it's okay so yeah and I mean
here it was kind of nice tactics but um
yeah it's important of course for me
that you know after I'm not losing after
Rook D7 because scary yeah I this and my
king you know hides so um and I'm
winning so he has no defense against
Rook H1
you yes I mean yeah he has to yeah I
mean the draw is like the normal result
so yeah I'm quite pleased with this game
because I'm not quite you know a bing
player and it looks you know like very
mature bettering stuff from black side I
hope so yeah so it's a good start you
had black pieces today and tomorrow who
are you playing and I think I think
Richard Robert Richard Robert okay yeah
white yeah okay so it's good I mean that
you have white pieces after that yes so
what who do you think will be fighting
here in this tournament for like two
places like regarding the shape of I
guess everyone know like I so far it's
hard to say yeah yeah a lot of short
draws indeed um yeah but you know it's
um yeah I guess people will be very
solid you know trying to squeeze with
white and be ultra solid with black and
um but I mean we'll see what happens
there like it's difficult to predict I
mean anyone can win this event so um
yeah it's too soon to talk about that
exactly three draws so far and okay
let's go back to the studio to Y sir
your Fe Anastasia thank you for that and
joy that that position that he is just
analyzing I'm forcibly reminded of the
advice that it depends and these Bishops
of opposite color position who's on the
attack but we just saw a very unique
case of white mating Black's King and
white mating yeah the other kings of the
Bishops the the both players were
attacking with their opposite color
bishop and draw was a satisfying outcome
Peter yeah youngster stuff I think said
that he was completely fine with this
outcome and I think the the end of that
game is quite unique just as you
described because normally normally one
side is is attacking and the other is
defending and exactly somewhere from
here I'm not going to repeat what
youngers have just said because he gave
a very comprehensive picture of what's
Happening Here but this position where
seemingly both sides are one move away
from delivering a final blow and in fact
it ends up being a draw and in fact this
Rook d8 check move is the only one that
makes a draw cleanly right right going
back to seven sort of makes a draw but
you'll have to work for it a little bit
so this very very cute little tactic
with throwing the rook in to make sure
all four Rooks come off is is a nice
touch by Anish but yeah very interesting
game very sharp burlin and ends quickly
enough that we don't get upset I think
it's a it's an important quality in a
buron end game Rook d8 that was
satisfying for sure as uh we're going to
jump to the game of leavon mvl and
leavon when we left that you were
mentioning you always had it in your
mind to go F5 F4 for leavon sacrificing
upon Pawn well guess what leavon agrees
with you wholeheartedly and he he got in
the H5 to provoke the H4 and the pawn
sacrifice um yeah it was something uh I
liked uh from the moment uh it was first
proposed by Joy how about you Peter I I
think it's a very good version but also
I do want to say that the Y is abs
absolutely on fire today I think
everything she said is is turning out is
turning out to be completely she's
reading the mind of of the players not
only she refuting what I'm saying she's
also seemingly reading the minds of the
players of the tournament which is I'm
very good at spotting blunders by the
way useful skill if you can if you can
have it the idea here of course we've
included after F4 um after F4 and uh e
takes A4 there uh in this position uh
we're throwing in Bishop F5 because it's
the best Square for this bishop and
we're also attacking The Rook on B1 so
winning a Tempo but the fall off will be
G5 G4 we're never taking any of these
pawns but wherever The Rook goes we're
playing G5 G4 and we're saying yes the
bishop still has squares but compared to
how good it was on this diagonal on the
H2 ba8 diagonal wherever it goes uh it's
not going to do very much and in fact
after Bishop takes G4 here the engine
actually prefers black but interestingly
even this move which leaves white with
an outside passer
which you can protect after some like
even a position like this with white
having no immediate targets and a
completely healthy extra passer on H4 is
according to the engine completely fine
for black because of just how much
better the black light pieces are
compared to the white light pieces so a
very I think sound positional Pawn
sacrifice there by Leon and then Maxim
is now choosing squares for his pieces
because pretty much every single move
along the back crank here is available
and can be argued for so it's it's a
tough choice I don't think he runs very
many risks here does mvl but I think
he's also coming to the realization that
he's not better at all and perhaps if he
can find a way to swap everything down
and just to make sure the game doesn't
enter potentially somewhat Dangerous
Waters uh he will be quite uh in favor
of that thank you Peter and uh just
turning once again to our attention to
the game between lanir and Bobby when we
have left it we've left it here with
this move Queen takes A4 Rook D2 and for
me I have to say Joy I I know the the
engine really liked Queen B5 and
slightly preferring it over Queen C4
they weren't obvious to no I mean I
remember we were during the break I I
said to you I actually don't think that
one will naturally play that move
because why would you and so I I
actually said The Rook will come to f8
and you were right you were right you
defended to F5 but on the other hand the
engine got very excited when it saw the
move rook f8 and it said the move we've
been aspiring towards uh that break G3
G4 is perfectly timed let's go G3 G4 and
now you really do have to pull the
brakes because uh you basically have
only one move to stay in the game the
attack White's attack is coming
frightfully quickly uh Peter and that
move was Queen E8 which yeah Faby did
fine you pretty much have to drop drop
the queen back stop the attack for the
time being because the trade of Queens
still favors black quite a bit here
black still has this passer on A4 the
material is equal yes we lost the H5 P
but we did pick up the pawn on A4 but of
course ler is entirely uninterested for
the time being in the queen but I have
to say that here seemingly the two moves
to choose from are queen d8 which I
think is the move that Fab will be
instantly drawn to right and move Queen
B5 which he hasn't found once already in
this game and it also no longer works as
well because very importantly if we
compare this position with the one we
had earlier with Queen B4 with the queen
on G5 white actually creates threats a
lot faster on the king side now if you
play Queen B4 here you pretty much even
C3 is very strong but then white will
start ganging up on the G5 and mate
happens faster on the king side here
than anything connected with A4 happens
on the queen inside so Queen B5 exists
it doesn't lose because in this position
it goes Queen C7 and even a quiet move
like this shockingly Rook takes A4 Rook
takes E4 A4 you have to play B4 Rook E8
the moment this happens to the white
king you actually get a lot of
counterplay against it but this doesn't
equalize it it completely equalized
earlier here it doesn't here it maybe
makes a draw with absolutely perfect
play but you're clearly uh fighting
against it and after Queen d8 shockingly
even the end games are now uh good for
white because in this position white
goes either Rook E6 or Rook E7 and the
white Rooks are more active also the
white the white king you can much easier
imagine the white king join joining The
Fray getting from I don't know from B1
to B5 right eventually whereas the black
king will just be a source of worry I
suspect the engine holds this it's
currently it says it says 070 with the
only move Rook B8 which is not going to
be a pleasant move to make by the way
right putting your Rook on a very
passive square and just for the time
being trying to defend everything very
very solidly I would be very nervous
yeah but but I think you're you're in
absolute panic mode here with right and
Quin qu8 on the board by the way I had a
feeling that having not played Queen B5
on move 29 Fab was Fabby was very very
unlikely to play it on move 31 yeah is
this for Rook ending again uh I
understand the Golden Rule but it seems
to me that lanir doesn't really have a
very good way of avoiding I think I
think you have to go for it because
playing Queen H5 not only does Queen E8
repeat but there is potentially maybe
even a stronger square right so why are
we giving black additional options
agreed so once again the four Rook
ending after takes
takes Queen takes Rook takes yeah you
can try playing G6 here but it's weaker
than Rook takes E4 Rook E7 the other the
trade because I mean this one looks very
good but is it tempting perhaps to go
and now I think after GF here Rook d8
we're probably making a draw because we
will be able to take we'll be able to
take on F5 next move and you have to
spend the tempo on Rook D2 Rook D2 or
Rook D4 whichever one you choose and
you're trading and then you you've lost
the D5 Pawn as well and this really
looks like I'm probably still picking
white but this looks like a drone
yeah thank you Peter yeah and they've
repeated actually but they are somewhat
short on time so I'm not expecting ler
to actually repeat the entire three
times and not play I have a feeling that
he's just doing the due diligence and
getting closer to 30 second just a quick
question I mean what we saw there was a
very long line and how easy is it to
assess the resulting position there with
the end game I think the players are
actually they're so conversent in these
Rook endings they're so incredibly
knowledgeable I do believe that they're
making uh quick an accurate judgment
calls uh Joy if the question I'm trying
because honestly it probably takes a
little while because for the time being
the king in some positions might be
might be uh a problem but the Rook on G5
covers white attacking the G7 pawn and
it seems like black is pushing pawns on
the queen side but in fact and this is
very uh illustrative I think we go Rook
B6 we force your Rook into a poor square
and then actually do something that I
was talking about this king is very much
aiming to go to B3 A4 B5 but this you
kind of find once you get to this
position right and uh but before before
you make the choice in getting there you
have to actually just quickly assess
superficially almost
right Jud and I'm I'm not I'm not sure
whether well well this and then we do
see the players repeating that's only
one I think yeah that's only once for
now this illustrative line where the
king where you played B5 B4 and the King
slalomed its way up to the B5 Square
shows why you play the move Rook B8 and
I think that that is very that is not to
find no that's for me the tough one
right there but we're looking we're
looking at this from From linear's
perspective because it's clearly lineer
called to repeat or not black can not be
better here black is very much asking
for white to repeat the moves here and I
think fer if he gets to this position
and thinks about it for 30 seconds he
will realize that he has absolutely zero
risk and might be better right I don't
know if I would instantly recognize that
it's something significant but I think
lineer is quietly a very ambitious
player I think he you know he has a very
unassuming demeanor he is an incredibly
polite and well-mannered and kind person
but he's also a very very strong and a
very ambitious player so I think he'll
continue I mean I might have to eat my
words in about 3 seconds I also have a
question on the current position as well
I mean could there be options for Lena
to keep the Queens on the board so not
go Queen to G5 but go Queen H and then
with the idea of going G G5 and then
Rook H3 and let's have fun that way
exactly well the idea of keeping the
Queens is very much I think uh that
that's that white would favor however
after Queen
H4 after Queen H4 it's it's a very
interesting option because and I he
might actually gravitate towards that
because Queen d8 G5 is playable but
Queen H3 is maybe even stronger because
now you can no longer offer Queen trade
and we will start opening up the G file
and putting things on like The Rook to
G3 Rook to G2 right this suddenly once
again the engine might hold it but it's
unfair that the engine might hold it it
feels like you should be losing here uh
so the option to find here by the queen
H3 immediately play Queen H3 immediately
very interesting not even uh so no uh
you don't have to eat your words you
correctly guess that underneath that
very uh kindly man is a a burning
cauldron of ambition Queen H3 Peter I I
like that move that that move asks a
question absolutely the king site is
opening up and the queen side is not no
no black pretty much needs to play Queen
G6 the same would have been true by the
way against Queen H4 as well with the
idea of going GF here here Queen takes
F5 actually uh hits the queen on H3
which is a difference and we get
interestingly and this is also I think
completely
counterintuitive it's like the end game
we were discussing I have a but but
white is a pawn up and white is to move
and this is apparently less less of an
edge Edge than the other one I give up I
don't really understand any of this
challenge yeah and and another another
thing to say here is that if you play
something like Rook G2 black might be
obliged to play Queen H7 and also how
happy are you going to be playing a move
like Queen G6 H7 which wow legitimately
seems like the only one that doesn't
lose on the spot because the threat of
gf5 Queen F5 let's say you make a very
natural move Rook A8 and it appears you
have already lost lost next move Rook e
G3 yeah you will not be able to trade
Queens off if you try playing something
like Queen F6 you get hit by Rook G6 and
you just get you just get M you just get
completely overrun on the king side so
yeah Fabby will have to play well from
here here's the conclusion I
think I mean are we in only move
territory actually with Queen to G6 I
think so uh once again it's hard to
judge whether this plus one it gives
white after takes G4 is already decisive
advantage on bigger depth or still
somehow manageable if you play extremely
well but there is a gulf between que G6
and everything else okay wow well
Fabiano potentially in a lot of trouble
against Lena Dominguez once again I I
I'm still kind of reeling Queen G6 Rook
G2 Queen
H7 yeah Queen G3 and now you play Rook
E8 and you claim that we we we brought
our pieces into the game white with a
rook on E3 not being able to be
teleported teleported to H3 or G3 I need
to capture my own Queen to get my my my
doubled Rooks and then eventually uh
against Queen F2 it it actually even
finds time to play B5 before which is
really stunning to me like where does it
find the time to spend two temp be on
that I will never know and and and Peter
after Rook E8 I take on F5 I'm assuming
you play Rook takes F5 I go Queen G4
with the idea of Rook H3 tra strictly
only move Rook
F7 everything else res everything else
resigns everything else resigns get is
cuz after Rook H3 you are offering a
trade of Queens everything else resigns
but King of8 zero on our screen now
because we're prepared to
run I thought I I was killing it and uh
you're telling me Triple zeros just no
Edge whatsoever anymore wow are frankly
if you if you get here those will be
findable right because the choice will
be that or resigns and they are not
illogical but the question is assessing
correctly that putting the queen on H7
for some moves will be okay I just kind
of wanted to say like in that final
position where we had where the king is
prepared to run okay the computer might
say it's 0.00 but they know scratched
that that's a god plane chess right on a
practical level really I think I I think
hold a position like this honestly I
think it's manageable because you have
your own trumps you you prepared to push
the forward if if nothing is happening
and imagine the same position with the
King on D7 black I think once it gets
closer to the queen side black will
start feeling quite confident and it's
very linear because because the pieces
left yeah so I think I think it's
manageable but it's not going to be fun
finding all of these moves uh but Fabby
obviously is quite well known as a
fantastic calculator of variations so
great I take him to find all of this
stuff and it's definitely lir who is
putting on the pressure with this move
Queen H3 will Fabby fine this very very
narrow path he's got 29 minutes is that
am I read
correct I think maybe seven
moves okay difficult moves but yeah
eight moves eight moves so five is seven
moves all in year until they reach the
first time control let's jump our
attention to the game between mvl and uh
leavon because I'm seeing a very
different structure than I had expected
because there's actually still a black
pwn on F4 how did that happen here that
was an interesting uh an interesting
choice by by leevon because we were here
and I actually said every single Square
on the back rank makes sense and I
thought does Rook e one make sense I
wasn't so sure but that's that that
ended up being his choice he got and you
were expecting G5 G4 no I think if you
if they give us the pawn on4 why not
take it because as you will see black
can even throw in the move Rook E8
because if if the bishop goes somewhere
Rook E2 might become quite annoying so
white actually played King F1 and after
G takes F4 King
F2 I'm not even I was going to say I'm
not sure I can imagine a sequence of
events which results in the F4 Pawn
getting picked up but actually Knight F1
Bishop D2 might be a threat and very
fast uh let's check if let's say if we
go King G6 and white goes Knight F1
right oh we're still in time it says
Bishop D2 Bishop A6 I mean Bishop A6
that we just go from from from this side
and we pick up the pawn on C4 and
frankly if that happens I'm starting I'm
starting to think long term maybe black
can be better wait a second why does
black have to waste the time with King
G6 why not just do it
immediately yeah this is the I mean it
allows 94 which is maybe not such a
uhhuh such a comfor able thing to allow
the engine likes it the engine thinks
Knight E4 Knight B7 and then we can just
kick it away with Bishop F5 again it
will have to go back to D2 then we will
plant our Knight on D6 and think we've
improved but I think
psychologically uh allowing Knight D2 E4
here when this Knight has been
completely sort of restricted by the
bishop on F5 might not be uh so easy and
also I just wanted to see if King G6 was
losing a kind of a normal move that also
allows Knight f one it was curious to me
to see whether we already needed to play
Bishop C8 or if we had time to spare and
it seems like we do have time to spare
well one other question I have for you
Peter if you did play a a lame move like
King G7 and if I did go into this bishop
of alus schull with Knight
B3 because if I could pick up F4 for
free I against King G7 KN B3 is
borderline winning apparently because
after the captures happen right uh we
need we need the King on F5 right down
on E3 and say Bishops of opposite color
ah that A7 B6 C5 I would be very very
dark squares I go Bishop
G3 and the immortal words of Larry
Christ I just wanted to point it out
I'll I'll get you from
behind Bishop and GES a draw Bishop to
B8 is the issues there oh my gosh and
and it's bottoming out it says plus four
currently so four this apparently is
just completely lost I wouldn't I
wouldn't have been so sure but it looks
risky because white I think can uh open
up a lot of a lot of potential Play
Because king of 4g4 probably generates a
passer on the H file as well yeah
Anastasia has been encouraging you to
check out the social media and there's
some really wonderful reasons why uh be
prior to the rapid and Blitz we inducted
three people very very very deserving
into the World Chess Hall of Fame it was
a a marvelous ceremony at the Webster
University as
uh Susan pogar the great chess coach of
Webster University was shall we say in
her glory at the spice building world
champion exactly absolutely fantastic
and the the the dean of the the
university the college was there and
some very heartfelt words dear friend uh
bent Larson who's no longer with us lios
reporters had done a video uh telephone
in and uh he got a lot of laughs uh for
uh his views of the Chess World today it
was it was a very very very nice
ceremony all of that uh yeah and the on
our social media and their pictures and
their stories will be there on the walls
of the Hall of Fame so please go and
check it out exactly two games out of
the five uh remaining and uh this one
Peter uh again it's the theme of the
round I don't know what exactly happened
but Bishops of opposite colors the
current position King has been played in
the meantime and it did look like a kind
of a normal move that exactly if you
don't want to play Bishop C8 immediately
you pretty much play King G6 because
everything else looks uh e and just to
illustrate why such a big difference
between King G6 and King G7 in this
position we will be quite happily
playing something like this and meeting
Bishop D2 with King F5 exactly this is
the square where it needs to be yeah
that makes all the difference in the
world sorry yeah that's what I was going
to say get the King on get the King on
F5 protect the little guys all is good
so that really leaves us with laner and
how close is he and of course Queen G6
on the board as you as as as I I said
yeah expecting Fabby to miscalculate in
positions where all that is required
from him is just very very
solid uh linear calculation is yeah
Fool's erant he's very very good at this
is that a deliberate Pond by the way
Lena
linear
no I wish I was that no he's
clever a clever
voice a little too fast on that one what
for me I want to say was I found very
surprising in the analysis that you
showed was that after Rook G2 Rook to E8
no we have have to Rook E8 takes on F5
resign after Queen H6 it's just it's
just dead over but I mean wouldn't you
go Rook uh Rook F7 Rook H3 and then hak
mate yeah or Rook still still not hake
mate because you can still
run but it's uh it's much less pleasant
but maybe Rook G3 you could toss in
after Rook F7 Rook G3 as a
prelim I wanted you to go rookie we're
still we're still winning I wanted you
to go to rookie s so you take away your
hiding spot r h and no more hiding good
spot good spot by yeah nice uh but that
for me is really surprising how how just
over it is uh uh on the turn rookie only
move Queen H7 only move Queen H7 and
another interesting part of course is
that your choice here is pretty is
pretty obvious you have this end game
right where the extra PA where you're
Pawn up and and it's your move and you
can play Rook A4 and trade F4 for A5 or
you can play Rook E7 and try to trade F4
trade F4 for B7 and you have to assess
whether this gives you anything at all
and like you have to be very very
certain that you're correctly
understanding just how how little there
is in let's say this position I'm not
sure why yeah that's not obvious at all
no cuz once again imagine this king is
on A4 already you're winning yeah and
probably because of that black has time
to play B7 B5 just to take away all of
these squares from from the the white
plans and then it goes King F6 and then
eventually I think it goes Rook H5 and
starts reminding white that there are
these three guys need to be constantly
constantly kept an eyon and uh yeah
apparently this is completely equal I'm
not sure how obvious that is but I think
the temptation to keep the Queens on
might must be very strong here right uh
two things uh to think about again the
temptation to keep the Queens on that
that rook and pawn ending with the extra
Pawn you know again I'm just so tempted
by that extra Pawn I would have thought
that I was going to uh be a two result
game sign me up right yeah remind us
again that their head tohe head between
these two uh players uh know each other
very well as lanir was one of the
helpers of uh fa Fabby during the 2018
World Championship Match yes and there
you can see their head-to-head scores
two wins for lenia Dominguez and four
wins for Fabiano Carana there so Fabiano
edging that out but 16 draws and very
interestingly
enough Dominguez has never lost game not
one of those four losses came from the
singfield cup not one as uh lanir is one
of those uh players uh Peter uh again we
we we know laners an excellent excellent
player uh this idea that he's been such
a hard man to beat in the singfield cup
that was a big bit of a surprise yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't have guessed that
without our statisticians coming up with
that particular TCT even though yeah I I
personally have found it very difficult
to win a game of chess against ler and I
think maybe I've won some rapid and
blitzes but classicals I don't recall a
single one of off the top of my head
exactly I have huge respect for him as a
player yeah do you know when uh you see
a play and you just watch his games you
well there you can see the stats he's 40
years old USS rating of 2723 represents
the United States and is a few five-time
Cuban chess champion and what I wanted
to say about his style was that reminds
me of a a systematic way of playing
chess and all he's looking for is that
1% getting better on a daily basis
that's exactly it compounding
Improvement
is uh what lineer is all about and by
the way for that URS just to explain to
everybody the universal rating system
was a brainchild of Gary Kasparov and
the idea was today rapid and Blitz has
become so important uh to uh the players
it's not just about getting your
classical chess rating really high so
you get those top uh um invitations but
the universal rating system was the idea
of combining all disciplines of chess
the rapid the Blitz and the classical
under one uh umbrella number and that's
what the URS is all about it's not the
feed day it's not the USCF Universal
rating system and Peter today I wanted
to say that uh we just had Tony Rich uh
to talk about the grand chest tour and
wrap it in Blitz uh yourself where do
you find yourself gravitating to do you
trying to improve it classical Blitz
standard I would say stand I'm trying to
impove improve my
standard with with arena being a
sideshow uh but uh on a more serious
note I used to be uh a purist I used to
think that classical is important and
everything else is a fun and very
enjoyable but far less Ser exhibition
yeah and weirdly the older I get the
more I like the shorter time controls
and the less the less I like the
classical probably because uh it's hard
work just very very hard work and I I've
become allergic to it how about yourself
allergic to hard work no yes on that
level absolutely but I'm changing but uh
what I want to say I have two hats here
so as a commentator I vastly prefer the
rapid format and in fact I would even
slash the classical time control I would
scrap having um extra time on move 40
just have everyone play like one and a
half hours move uh no move 40 and just
have this increment 30 second um as AER
have you felt have you ever thought of
running for the feay presid as a player
as a player I very much appreciate that
break that you get on true the
40 you can just of Rel get that extra
time have some uh time just to work out
what's happening on the board but I do
feel like chess is speeding up it needs
to speed up because you know it's become
much more accessible to everyone these
days and it's demanding on your time
right if for viewers or for observers if
they have to spend six seven hours
looking at a classical game I feel like
Society isn't quite ready ready well
it's not that they they were ready for
but now they've moved on and everything
is about instant gratification so we've
got to keep up in the Chess World well
what the the whole conversation forcibly
reminds me of the
2018 world championship match where uh
the 12 classical games were all drawn
and we were very critical of Magnus in
the very last game he had the black
pieces but the position he had on the
board everybody felt was very
advantageous to him and that if he won
that game he would he would win the
match so what's the problem play the
position on the board play for the
advantage and he went IM immediately for
a draw and his idea was that they were
going to now play Four rapid games to
determine the world championship and in
magnus's mind he would rather play 200 g
200 moves right because that's what the
four Rapids uh games were all about than
one classical game of 40 50 moves and to
get as many decisions in as possible so
today Magnus is really very strongly
favoring rapid and Blitz he's becoming
Advocate if you will and he gave up his
classical title yeah absolutely you know
he he says it's much more exciting and
and it is but I mean it is in kind of
the sense that it's faster you know it's
adrenaline packed it's a rush yeah and
as a commentator you commentator you
know I absolutely love it right you know
the drama the story lines and here it
just feels like it is a leely place pace
so for instance we had this very
exciting game and when the games are
like this okay I think it's very good
that we have a classical time control
but when the games are kind of perfect
and uh neither side wants to give ground
and it just as we've seen in the three
draws ends up in a
drawer it is exciting but in a different
kind of way you know it's much more
exciting for for players on a
theoretical level and of uh three draws
we might be uh seeing a fourth coming up
uh Peter yeah I want to venture a
suggestion that something along the
lines of Rook C1 Bishop B3 Rook C3
Bishop A4 Rook C1 Bishop B3 looks pretty
good here right uh it's a it's a fun
party game to play and as you can see
I'm very much fun at parties uh trying
to find the exact threefold that the
players will will choose nobody can make
any progress here the F4 Pawn is the
only real weakness on the board it has
been completely soundly covered by the
King on F5 have one way to improve you
think Rook D3 is better or uh no I was
just thinking A6 B5 you know there is an
opening there okay but uh but then your
C5 PA becomes becomes a Target is E2 is
what you're saying yes you wanted you
wanted to take on B5 well you don't even
need A6 for that you could just yeah
Bishop takes and Rook e two rookie is is
a threat now even this position is still
is still fine but this you can
understand but if B5 doesn't actually
Force white to to recapture we can start
by playing let's say Rook C3 C1 because
bc4 Rook C4 F4 is also going to hang I
think it's extremely unlikely that Leon
will entertain very many thoughts in
this direction because even the absolute
best scenarios seem like they're still
equal and I'm not sure you're could you
could you for instance go Bishop B3 and
okay this this is really Taking
Liberties I understand yeah you you need
to be able to recapture with the bishop
to create the thir of Rook I wanted to
trap The Rook but uh ah trap it's a
and then after rout tc5 I just wanted to
go there but and D6 D6 check and we kind
of collapsing
because coming in I I really don't think
I mean we'll see Leon is also definitely
someone who if he feels this gives him a
modum of a chance I think he'll go for
it because white really is completely
stuck uh so I white is yeah white has no
breaks you're you're right in the sense
joy that it's black who can who can
change alter I'm not going to play G3 I
don't want to play G3 and I don't want
to play
D6 cuz I feel like if I played D6 I
could easily just end up losing yeah the
pawn on D6 so I'm stuck as white you
know because you know that if this were
a
2700 player playing against
24400 they would be thinking how do I
imbalance and you know they would be
looking at ways of going A6 B5 maybe
bishop comes
D1
right some kind of so yeah so white
starts with Rooks well I like what Peter
was trying to do Peter was trying to
guess the three move repetition and he
was thinking Rook C1 was the Prelude to
the three move repetition we were we
were very much against this but uh but
there we are G3 takes G3 happen takes
takes I'm assuming Rook e 2 is
completely fine in fact most things will
disappear of the board I guess the uh
the calc ulation here is that yes all of
these will fall but so will all of those
and something like this is actually
perfectly logical I can include a
six and we go and something like
something like this might be might be a
logical followup I'm a bit surprised by
this I didn't think it was called for
but on the other hand we are now
generating ideas of perhaps Rook E3 or
on a good de Bish by before let's say
currently it's impossible because of I
also spotted one idea is it to Rook E2
yes is it possible to go Rook to D3 once
again I'm Taking Liberties yeah oh this
is why you guys are super Grand Masters
you spot my ideas instantly it's
perfectly sound and weird I was I was
trying to find some way to give M to
this King on G3 right uh but I'm not
fast enough to play Bish F my my Brook
is in the way but shockingly and
somewhat it feels like life is a bit
unfair because you you you found this
fantastic Cho and rookie 8 is still
completely fine oh no it's actually not
doing very much you you you want to
deserve more you know you're you're more
deserving than the half point you know
the Haring of the point the Haring of
the
point I'm not check and actually both
King moves are even fine like I can even
allow D7 Bishop a 4 C7 because I always
have Bishop A4 as a reply even this is
just completely fine I don't know
Bishops of opposite color is it's the
it's the bane of uh the modern Chess
World that uh we will have four gam four
games end in a position with opposite
colors which is quite something right
and I do I do agree with you uh Peter
that I see the move Rook E3 is a threat
of forcing everything just to get
actually a little bit iffy because if
you imagine I'm I'm just giv please
please please you would much rather
trade with the bishop already on F4
because here your your structure does
fall it's still a draw because of the
same maneuver right but you'd never
really like being the second one to
start picking up stuff right you want to
be the first one to capture something
even though this actually is still
perfectly manageable yeah okay which
again uh leaves us with the laner uh
Fabby match now I haven't been uh told
this so I just need to get a
clarification on our social media
obviously Anastasia is posting great
stuff B
posting great stuff I don't know if
we're actually inviting questions I'll
uh I'll uh get that uh from our
production team if we do want Twitter
questions what's is what has happened
Peter well after Queen H7 we were
arguing that uh from a purely human
perspective it's just so attractive to
try to give mate right but ler once
again I'm I'm guessing he's just he's on
very very good form seemingly today
because this
is safer also maybe objectively stronger
than Queen G3 because uh already on the
first off in this position fa had to
find the only move Rook af8 it's not a
difficult move but still everything else
was borderline losing because you
absolutely have to have defense against
Rook E7 Rook D5 Rook E7 Rook G8 you
already lose like it looks completely
lost this is you can't you can't play
this end game with with one Rook being
completely on a passive Square so Rook
f8 to have Rook F7 if if the Rook with s
yeah and once again we have a position
where white is a pawn up white has a
move you can even spend a Tempo on
something like King A2 because Rook D5
Rook D5 Rook E7 is still very strong and
Rook takes F4 you can play Rook E6 and
then try to once again do you do your
slum on the on the queen side the engine
holds this but I don't know how
comfortable of a hold it
is Jump In
Joy I don't think it's like very
comfortable hold at all I mean it's one
thing definely two result game as we do
see the the the the the players found
one of those sequences uh Peter where
you the white the white Bishop just
takes everything on the dark squares and
the light squared Bishop takes
everything on no I'm just I'm just
laughing because I mean we were like
biging up the stats yeah we were I mean
what are the chances that you we would
get four games and four of them would be
opposite color Bishops and the decisive
white the the decisive first round
victories lead to the winner of the
tournament we had these beautiful stats
whole tournament off yeah there nobody's
going to win this
tournament it will be a 10-way tie for
first place at the end in the playoffs
has that ever happened no no not that I
no
uh I I I wanted to say this Halloween I
I don't know what happened but I went
out I'm not joking I bought like 5 lbs
of candy expecting all the
trick-or-treaters to come and raid the
house well I got raided but only like
one pound so I like four
PB holoween chocolates you know stuffing
myself with Almond
Joys I got kitkats and almond anybody
wants to come over I'm your guy I'm your
connection to Almond Joys and kitkats
and Hershey's Kisses okay I don't know I
don't know about yourself so yeah we
were all dressed up and nobody showed up
to the party today as we're expecting a
fourth draw in at this the first round
which one do you choose Bishop A7 or
Bishop C7 here oh A7 for sure because
that allows King E5 King
D6 there was a reason I was asking oh
well we f f and
sinker well we sure did fall forward s
it doesn't win though no it doesn't win
so you you can definitely play Bishop A7
if you want it's still a draw but for a
second there I thought maybe bishop A7
actually allows to give this game to
pretend pretend it's still a game for a
bit longer but no that is that is an
amusing uh point and and oh no here put
the bishop on A7 it was just too
irresistible and now right Simply
Irresistible we would expect Bishop D3
although Peter is making the point that
with the move King E5 Bishop takes B6
there is the move King D6 and I and The
Who and we don't get completely
liquidated quickly showing his fighting
Spirit jobs there with with the move
King E5 but is it really
no and will play Bishop A7 here give a
check from B8 and then go back to A7 I
was about to say fighting chops Bishop
B8 check yeah first take the Pawn King
will come back to D6 to defend or no is
he going to play King D4 King D4 D6 King
D6 King D4 D6 Bishop A4 right yeah but
then bishop d8 and you lose the F6 Pawn
as well and you start entering some kind
of that's not what I wanted King D6 can
you also just go King F4 and you know
once the bishop moves yeah take the King
on F6 yeah also completely fine also yes
but we we would expect Bishop A7 Bishop
D3 Bishop B8 check and the repetition
that
way is reaching for it yeah that would
be the most
professional but we have seen sadly and
that is the state of modern chess
accuracy accurate games JY every game
absolutely accurate yeah I me such such
as uh life and such as chess well that
was what Wesley said you know to to to
win in modern chess you need your
opponent to make a mistake if they don't
make a
mistake Jess is raw maybe yeah it is and
Bishop who said that who who who
famously said that
line and uh oh the the Chinese player
who he just came onto the scene and he
was extremely famous and he his first
two or three years of playing Elite
tournaments he was basically seemingly
aiming for slightly worst end game worse
end games with both colors right and
then winning like 35% of them and
drawing the rest there we see the
players repeating
with Maxim giving a check and Leon
retreating
and yeah this will be drawn in a moment
will be our fourth draw and then round
and then in an interview yeah he was
absolutely the darling of the the the
Press Center in the Baku Grand Prix I
think it was
2009 I want to say maybe eight and
people adored him there because he spoke
this very nice English it was was a
limited but very kind of well-mannered
and polite English and at some point he
played yet another petro and Drew yet
another petro and people asked him what
he thought about it he kind of shrugged
and said maybe chess is
D nice as we do see the two players
looking at one another good game good
game all around F5 F4 leavon kind of
kind of threw his patties he he got in
some shots but uh the initiative the
slight initiative he had was not enough
draw and fourth draw in a row fourth
draw out of five which again leaves us
our Rook ending Peter uh Rook f8 as you
were mentioning on the board and ler is
thinking he has options here he needs to
sort of weigh I'm a pawn grubber let let
me try my best desperately to hold on to
the pawn I'll go Rook to E7 you'll go
Rook F7 I'll trade a pair of
Rooks I'll go Rook G4 cuz I want to
defend my Pawn you'll go Rook F5 or just
goes B5 for the B5 because otherwise I
was going to go C4 C4 actually makes a
decent amount of sense exactly exactly
now in this position and if you do this
it will actually spend the tempo playing
B5 before and now Rook F5 is a mass is
going to is going to win the PA you can
you don't need to hurry Rush with a B3
let's let's go C3 no rushing yeah no
rushing Rook B5
this is our issue
uh R rushing was needed well I rushing
rushing was also not getting you
anywhere it wasn't getting as there you
haven't made a mistake but you've also
not preserved the PA didn't get a chance
to preserve the pawn some of my Rook
ended up very passively how do I okay so
in this position sorry Peter if you
don't mind Rook to G3 so my idea might
be Rook F4 Rook to B3 yeah it it still
goes B5 but it also says this is still
fine you've got a check going going for
something like this and then eventually
going after the H Pawn and starting to
push the uh the G PA down the board I
wasn't thrilled either cuz you did have
Rook F1 check and Rook F2 and the pawns
were all getting liquidated as well this
begins getting a little bit excited
because I think uh what white wants here
is to enter enter race situation with
the C4 and D5 pawns against the D6 Pawn
because then if D6 Falls white will have
two in the center that run quite quickly
whereas if we consider uh this line
whenever the race gets initiated they're
on starting squares and it's much easier
for black to uh to to to play against
that good point valid by the way he
played do have Rook G4 he played Rook G4
a Prelude to Rook E7 and C4 and B3 and
all of those takes D5 is no longer
possible
yeah7 that's happiness that is because
we traded off and we got active
Rooks so I suspect we might be seeing a
B5 B5 or Rook F7 some kind of a
preparatory move B5 in particular I
think the engine likes in pretty much
every single position here but now I
have a cheapo don't I B5 Rook E6 Peter
so if you if you're
oh was about to say if I could indu let
me let me just check let me check how
bad this is because without the pawn on
B7 this becomes unpleasant but playable
right it would have been completely lost
if white were taking on seven in this
position but it's still bad notice
notice just how how uh much the engine
dislikes it despite it being equal
material is isn't there like
opportunities to trap the king you know
I'm thinking Rook F7 F5 oh even some
mating I going going for some mating
Nets yeah needs to be very careful here
okay good good well there's also the
usual plans of provoking A4 and then
trying to catapult our King from B1 to
B4 and just playing against the king
king queen side this is just quite
unpleasant for black I'm pretty sure
Fabi is not going to enter uh any of
this we do have B5 on the board by the
way Fab is very on point from the moment
he we feel maybe missed a very computer
is but a clean equality with the move
Queen B5 after Rook G2 from that moment
onwards I think we hasn't hasn't missed
a bit everything he's done since his ACC
is very very uh strong yeah his accuracy
has been fantastic by the way once again
for those of you who are joining us late
let's just loud the year that Fabiano
has had because he has had you know well
I mean a career defining
2023 Bucharest the grand chest tour uh
thank thanks to uh veran for pointing
out yeah what it's been like uh for Fab
absolutely I mean just take a look at
some of these achievements you know
first place as you say in the Bucharest
with
$100,000 in his pocket also fourth place
in Croatia World Cup third place
um in the24 candidates tournaments US
champion and of course
winning St Louis rapid and Blitz and
that's not the only thing cuz I can also
point to like he almost Norway chess if
it had not been for hiar Nakamura same
goes for the grand Swiss he was doing
exceedingly well and take a look at the
Grand chest T standings he literally he
would have to withdraw from the event
not to win the grand chest tour 2020 he
would have to have some major meltdown
and come last which is completely
unlikely in his form and uh there you
see it you know he has an 11o lead over
Maxi Vel graph which not only Nets him
additional money on the ground chest
tour but also secures him an invite into
next year's ground chest tour I'm sure
we will be inviting him I very recently
he had a podcast with uh Christian where
uh he was laughing because he was having
such a great result the
bookmakers had said that he would win
the aisle of man as well and this was
like the the strongest Swiss tournament
like ever in the history of mankind it's
notoriously difficult of course to win a
Swiss tournament to make him an absolute
favorite was ridiculous and he was
laughing and that he should go and bet
against himself but it's been that kind
of a year that the bookmakers actually
say okay he's going to win the aisle of
man as well and he actually came very
very close Hikaru uh upended him at the
very very end but just to remind every
everybody what's happened with our
results uh Joy it's a peaceful round so
very peaceful and there we see four of
the matches have ended in a draw between
vasra aronian Richard report Nashi G
Duda so fuia but there has been an
interesting twist all four of these
games have involved opposite color
Bishops yeah that's been the twist that
has been the most surprising for me the
game of Gary and dud
that was a that was a very uh strange
game Peter in the sense that when we saw
the move Knight takes B5 for the first
time we thought oh dear duda's blundered
Pawn but maybe it was actually an error
to may not may not have been the
strongest move in the position
surprisingly even even though it looked
extremely obvious and and good and and
solid uh to slightly expand what you uh
the topic you just finished discussing
about Fab's year we say that Anish is
leading the fed the circuit race for the
final candidate spot that's only because
Fabby has already qualified Fab is like
20 points clear of the field on the
circuit but he doesn't need it because
he's in he's in by the World Cup Yeah by
yeah so yeah it's that explains that one
it's it's been a year to remember for
sure for for fa exactly and I also I
remember B3 played in the meantime B2
3 by the way C4 being the threat that it
appears to be doesn't that provoke B4 by
it absolutely does even though
supposedly you can even ignore it the
engine even says something like this is
holdable which you can believe because
there's always like this Rook goes to H5
all of white pawns become targets and
yes I can definitely imagine this not
being winning but I think if you choose
between this and this I think you pretty
much always play
before and uh Anastasia is hosting
leavon in studio I will go over to
her welcome Leon to the studio I mean
this game was really interesting because
all your games against Maxim I think you
are fighting all the time and have very
good positions what can you tell about
this opening Choice today and what
happened uh yeah I think we were trying
to surprise each other uh and uh maybe I
managed to surprise him slightly more
with qu5 it's uh it's a little bit of a
rare
move um I think black is basically
asking white to take on F6 and play
knight2 that's more or less the what
would happen if if white will do so yeah
it's uh I mean it's it's a playable
position for black I think black needs
to take and then Ed Knight C6 something
like that is but you know um if if you
are not remembering the correct way to
play play for white then having those C3
uh D4 pawns is not a great joy I just
remember that like uh here you need to
play Knight
C6 and yeah black is fine somehow Knight
C4 King E7 something like that yeah and
Bishop C4 Queen G2 so it's not possible
to take with the bishop otherwise it
would be nice and I also remember that
here this bishop
A7 there are many ways for black to play
I thought Knight C6 I thought during the
game that it makes a lot of sense I just
develop and you know trying to play Rook
C8 so you were happy about your position
I thought it's a playable position and
we discussed with you now nowadays if we
got the playable position it's already
good news absolutely absolutely and then
so after Rook B1 KN A5 this uh happened
and I think you know I I I felt that
maybe should be slightly tiny bit more
comfortable for me to play but uh yeah
somehow it all you know depends on
details so for example this was more or
less logical what happened
so F1 okay Knight F5 I thought maybe I
can play with F6 but I thought Knight F5
is principal in fact my intention was to
meet D5 with F4 but then I kind of
um got uh yeah I think um after I
saw some things I wasn't so sure anymore
because yeah Knight D4 is coming and if
I play let's say here I didn't like G4
mhm you know his undermining my Bishop's
position so I'm not in time uh to to
lock the bishop in so then I told to
myself all right I will do the same
thing just a little bit later when the
moment arises and yeah so this what
actually happened I mean after Bishop G3
uh yes here Bishop G3 yeah King F7
Knight D2 Rook C8 this is all very
logical and uh yeah F4 I think is a good
move because I kind of Play Bishop to F5
and then just play G4 and structurally I
always have this maneuver with the
Knight to D6 for example if white block
yeah if white does something like let's
say Rook D1 G4 Knight F1 yeah I don't
have to worry much I just bring the
Knight and and then C4 Pawn will be
always yeah yeah and I think black black
should be fine here so and then uh so I
think we
both understood that the position is
more or less equal and the game went to
its natural uh path on on the natural
path yeah I mean I mean so we here King
F2 when he played um oh yeah kinging
first he played yes King F2 then he
decided to I mean first king of L and
king of two was the idea probably to
move the Knight yes yes like maybe that
was the last trick he tried to in this
game
know yeah but okay you didn't let him
yeah because now Knight F1 uh is met
with this and now if he goes this six no
wait sorry not Bishop C4 Knight C4 and I
think this six doesn't work because I
can take this oops check yeah King G1
Rook E1 and King G3 Rook e six Rook e
six wow two pieces are hanging yes so
everybody go CED everything and the game
finished in the end eventually finished
in the draw how did it feel for you to
play today same same playing hle as us
CH Championship but different event so
was it any difference well it's always
interesting to play against Maxim you
know he's always fighting so I uh he's
one of the players that uh I like
playing against because he's he's giving
chances and he's uh you know he's one of
those guys that uh
are um not settling for uh just uh
boring games but that's for sure yes so
it was a very fighting draw today thank
you so much Leon and all the best in the
next rounds thank you thank you
Anastasia thank you leavon coming up
actually after the event the uh closing
ceremony it's also combined with the
Gaya it's an annual fundraiser here in
St Louis so we have a silent auction and
we raise money for the entire year and
we have a very special guest Marina uh
will be for the strategy across the
board and we're all T told to raise our
raise our paddles and uh bid on The Many
Items uh that we will be on offer
brilliant and uh we are going to go on a
short break but during the break you'll
hear Anastasia she spoke to Ala fuia
earlier on in before the event and let's
hear what she had to
[Music]
say ala welcome back to St Louis welcome
back to grest yeah it's it's been a
while we saw you in grest of course you
played in Grand SS you appeared here
there but let's say what what you've
been doing for five months basically
like four or five months since ctia I
played Croatia it was in July yes now
we're on it's November it's November
okay October so two months I didn't play
in the middle yeah and let's say during
the summer yeah I was watching World Cup
chest and I was working on my chest and
um summer I didn't want to miss summer
that's I didn't want to spend one months
in aeran for summer where did you spend
this mon I been everywhere
Spain um it was cool times wow sounds
great who are some of your chess idols
and um how they influenced your chess
career yeah um all I always said is I
tried to learn from all the world
champions all of them are great but
Magnus is probably because when I
started playing chess he became world
champion so it was always years yes and
I started 2013 so it was always his name
there and we were trying to learn from
him so it would be a lie if I say
not you're definitely one of the let's
say the best players of this generation
but whom do you see also like you know
um really promising young CH players in
the world right now yeah um all the
Indians are scar to play
and these Five Guys from India are
really talented name them please because
they are so many I think GES
prandi of I I forgot probably name now
all of them are very good like each
tournament one of them will go up it
doesn't matter one of them will qualify
or will win so um they are very talented
so and usani players also they are very
good do you consider to study somewhere
in any University uh I was thinking
today like I was eating this Chick-fil-A
today in the university and I felt like
it's easier when going to study than
chess because should be less um nervous
stress because you don't lose to anyone
you just go to the test you read it and
you pass so it's it's cool Vibe but I
think I will get bored of it that's also
the problem which university would you
study if you had a chance um I don't
know I I like I like to be lawyer
because it's it will help me to CH also
and I think lawyer probably law study
yeah I studied law you see
it helped me with inter okaya thank you
so much and all the best of luck in the
tournaments thank
[Music]
you hello I'm women's Grand Master rim
to Jan I will be creating content for
Grand store follow us on social media
and catch more behind the scenes
content the St Louis ch Club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Lou chess club.org to
claim your membership today the World
Chess Hall of Fame located in the heart
of St Louis's historic Central West End
want to know why chess has intrigued
people around the world for nearly 1,500
years stop by and learn about the impact
of Chess from our three floors
showcasing the art culture and history
of the game the World Chess Hall of Fame
has something for everyone to enjoy for
more information on current exhibits
please visit World Chess h.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chest sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy the St Louis
chess club Scholastic program brings the
educational value of Chess to kids and
schools across the St Louis area active
in over 100 schools throughout the St
Louis city and county the St Louis chess
club has been able to reach over 85,000
students in both in school and after
school programs we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
seducation hello I'm women's grandm R to
janova I will take you behind the scenes
of the grand chest tour follow us on
social media and don't miss out on
players interviews and more content from
the playing
Hall the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen sinkfield and Rex sinkfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership ship
[Music]
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game
landmarked by the world's largest chest
piece sitting outside our front door the
world Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy including various
exhibitions monthly concerts and much
more whether you are a beginner or a
professional there is something for
everyone to learn here at the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy free admission
to our rotating exhibitions in our
Galleries and sign up for chess events
familyfriendly programming and art
classes and don't forget to stop by our
award-winning gift shop Q Boutique and
Shop a wide selection of Chess related
merchandise for more information on
current exhibits please please visit
World Chess h.org
[Music]
St leis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the worldclass St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the Junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of readand write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.com or/
[Music]
education we are back in round one
sville cup and so far we've had four
very precise draws as players just
playing very very well and take a look
at when you're there's not much you can
do exactly there and as you see it was a
draw between Maxine Vash lra leavon
aronian also an early draw between
Richard report and Yan piai who just
wheeled out some preparation and Nish
giri took on Duda but that also ended
peacefully and Wesley so and alira fuja
just played a perfect game such is life
but there is one game remaining that is
between lenia Dominguez Fabiana Carana
that probably has been the game of
around in terms of excitement and we've
been seeing we've been seeing the four
themes of the draws were all themed
draws of opposite color Bishop this has
not been that case no opposite color
Bishops in this one instead we have a
four Rook ending on the board and uh
Lena there in deep thought after Fabiano
plays Rook H5 attacking the H2 Porn uh
lanir
nursing the extra Pawn I want to say
Peter but it's not an extra Pawn where
he can really do much with it the
problem is I'm not even sure you can
preserve it for much longer I think he's
okay H4 would would do the job here he's
gone uh he's gone H4 here uh otherwise I
think black would be uh quite
comfortably attacking VAR or the other
like if you imagine white going Rook G
G4 G2 you just drop the Rook back to F5
I want to show one picturesque position
because it's a theme perhaps some of our
viewers have never seen if you play Rook
H4 Rook F2 this is still fine but it
seems like we've played Rook F2 to get
under play G5 get under a major major
pin and then suddenly surpris this
really weird position where every Rook
attacks every other rook and you can't
take both of them at the same time so
you end up uh losing here with black
because whichever one you choose to take
white will pick up the other uh so Rook
hf5 is more precise because of that
because now after Rook F2 you very
happily play G5 and in fact you start
thinking maybe I'll be better at some
point in this game so ler has gone H4 my
first question was can't we go Rook F5
but I have a response to that Rook G5
absolutely and this is supposedly still
fine
upsettingly
upsettingly I was quite smug about The
Rook G5 I was thinking that's it in the
back but I was thinking that after Rook
G Rook F5 I was going to play Rook D2
you would take the pawn I would play
Rook
G2 or I was thinking of Rook E4 you
would take the pawn I would play Rook
E7 but uh this is actually uh and once
again I'm very upset with my screen
because it seems to suggest that even
this is a draw no way uh which I dream
to get this position Fabby Fabby is good
at chess this is uh I'm coming to this
conclusion more and more it's not that
this idea is new to me but this game in
particular he just instantly goes Rook
F6 which is much stronger than Rook F5
because we're creating this idea of Rook
F6 G6 because this Rook on G4 is
protecting everything once it's removed
from the picture the king side will
start crumbling and in fact uh as the
engine already starts giving up uh
things and another difference here is if
you do the same right I have Rook G6 you
are not forcing me to give up on G7 so
Rook F6 very very precise move I I have
a question though okay so let's abandon
all hope on the king side and instead
what about trying to win the A5 pawn and
so I'm thinking first of all you go
C3 and then King C2 yep that pawn is
going to fall and then rook and then
Rook A4 oh yeah yeah sorry Rook takes
Rook this is still hanging though oh
that's annoying okay but okay okay we
can we can live on King takes
C3 and now Rook
A4 got it black made so much progress on
the other plank as well well you've been
doing your good deeds on the queen side
the king side just got uh and just
briefly to know that it might look like
we blunder a rook here with this
discovered check of four or five but in
fact uh the pawn ending is not uh like
Rook H4 loses here in fact the only way
to make a draw here apparently is to
play F6 and then go back to D I don't
know why this is a draw it looks it
looks it looks lost for it so yeah but
uh playing F5 is ill advised because
then life will demand studies from you
to survive uh Rook F6 is just a very
very solid decision by fabibi and with
every move that he makes it feels like
he's more and more in control and uh
yeah white of course can never be worse
being a pawn up in starting position
here like when you begin from from a
pawn up rook Rook ending you are not
expecting to lose but you probably by
this this point not expecting to win
either because Fabi has been playing
extremely solid chess starting from the
one you know quote unquote mistake
around move 30 where he didn't find what
engine was suggesting was a stronger
Choice I'm still laughing at ourselves
that we have come so very very well
prepared for for today's opening round
the the player who wins the first round
on the first day uh goes on to win the
tournament seven out of nine times the
players uh the
round one it's the most decisive uh if
we could have that graphic again so of
the nine rounds of the SW of the
sinkfield cup which round is the most
decisive you and I both in ited
obviously the penultimate round because
that's where you leave it all on the
table not even close but if we do get
that graphic it turns out that round one
here it comes Joy I mean we were so well
prepared for for
abely I mean just take a look at this
48.8% of the games have ended decisively
in round one in the sinkfield cup that
is that is going to be dramatically
reduced after today's round 48 not any
longer go on continue absolutely not and
there was a very nice graph as well
which showed the percentage of decisive
games and uh 48.8% was round one and
here you see it in round two it does
decrease to
39% and our prediction of round eight
well not even close not even close one
of the lowest ones
23.7% boy we are making history today
with this uh five draws and it does
again with very exacting play as you
pointing out by Fabiano Peter uh five
out of five uh one thing I thats badly
if the graphics hold up it it bods badly
for 2023 SFI cup if 48% of the games are
decisive and then they're all so we have
seen like a three-way tie in Singapore
Cup history but I mean have we
seen with other tournaments you know I'm
thinking what is the biggest tie for
first place that we've ever
seen uh you mean in terms of yeah major
other super yeah I mean I was involved
in a four-way tyer first at least once
maybe twice in the Russian championships
but those weren't round Robins those
were uh Swiss tournaments MH uh and
obviously there's a big difference in a
Swiss tournament you you have a much
larger field to to tie to tie for first
so it doesn't quite count but yeah
definitely there's been ties first
through fourth probably much further
even I I've SE well I I I don't I've
seen a lot of tournament tours where
players have been like on the 50% Mark
and maybe one person won it just by
winning a
game right and then one person coming
last just because they lost well I do
recall a number of US championships and
like these were the worst so the idea
was the top three players for example go
to the inter
zonal first and second no problem they
were all decided everybody's happy but
then you had a five-way tie for
third and normally speaking who cares
right you just everybody gets their
prize but because of the one
qualification you suddenly had five
players playing for one qualification
spot oh they bit ruthless though
sometimes they're like well you know use
the ti Breakers can't have the the
person who had the lowest tie break got
chucked out and then no no in those days
they used to have the time they they
they pretended like we have all the time
of the world to to to break these ties
but you know what I'm talking about one
one playoff guy and on the topic of uh
people having all the time in the world
my first serious Coach used to play in
this tournaments in the old Soviet Union
which lasted for like a month and a half
so right like special days set out for
for adjournments and also like rest
every two rounds and what have you and
uh those resulted in people enjoying
themselves judging by the I've never
played in any of those but from the
stories people would take the
opportunity to really kind
of right fly fly yeah gotcha well there
you go uh
bring bring us up
to it's it's a family show very nice
very nice just to to conclude with our
conversation about the stats in the
first round and decisive games having
watched what we just watched
uh any betting man out there bet on the
eighth round being by far the most deis
exactly now if we're so wrong about
round one I think it's logical to
conclude we will also be completely
wrong about round eight right but I I I
really felt Peter that we were so close
on this one I
mean not even not even close um lanir
seems to have gone in a bit of a tank
after Rook F6 uh they get 30 minutes for
the rest of the game he's down he's down
to 20 uh he made the time control and
he's down to below 20 there's still a 30
second increment none of this is a
problem and of course there's a huge
safety net of just simply the fact that
he's a pawn up in Rook ending right uh
so he's trying to establish whether
there's like any winning chances
anywhere at all and probably coming up
empty because it just doesn't seem like
there's any good defense against Rook G6
so for example King B2 let's go King B2
R G6 Rook G6 and I'm just I I come to
the same pathway that you did Joy I
wanted to go with the The Rook tray and
uh but C4 and we just get the same it's
the same position yeah we' here it's
fine like you can try running the king
upwards but but King F5 just as you
prescribed F4 is a draw I can also play
G5 and pretend but like all of this is
very much pretending but importantly
Rook a four is a draw what happen can
you run for the D6 Pawn uh in in maybe
not in this king of lost now we lost
Rook D3 Rook D3 or something King even
have King
E5 it says it's a draw so we we haven't
actually left the the equilibrium yet I
can I can start pushing my own my own
pawns because like I I will even be
perhaps abandoning D6 and play Rook F3
picking up on B3 so got no black is
really it feels like despite black being
a pawn down you can't even say you're
worse here with black the moment you
realize just how strong R G6 is against
whatever uh lineer might play I'm
wondering what happens if we drop the
Rook back back but then after Rook G6
okay it doesn't really help us very can
I oh D5 is hanging D5 is also hanging
three of them yeah exactly I was going
to take and play Rook G2 check but then
the idea was after King F6 Rook G4 but
Rook D5 thank you very much just to put
it on the board that was also my idea to
sort of replenish The Rook on G4 yeah
indeed uh we can we can
yeah but then still still a draw but you
start thinking okay this king is much
more
centralized we're definitely not playing
for a win here anymore agreed agreed
ouch and is and is it possible to I I
have an idea mhm and it involves either
C3 King King B2 just something like that
but the whole idea is that you jettison
the uh F Pawn at this point oh you go
like F5 check to preserve it I want to
preserve age4 that one's a lot more
critical yeah let's say I
mean let's see if like Rook F3 King C4
King F5 you you're not going to be
making very much progress with the King
being so active and also like I keep an
eye on the B3 point it just doesn't feel
like we're U going to be achieving very
much here somehow maybe the king needs
to be on
A3 right but you're not getting there
I'm not getting there am I right that's
the annoying part no not really no darn
it so it's understandable that he is
spending all this time because it feels
a bit unfair that you can't even find
the problem is we're struggling to name
an idea yeah we would like a question to
ask I I like to to phrase it like that
you would like to find a question to ask
Fabby to to solve right but so far we're
coming up very short on questions
exactly yeah the answers are there but
where's the question how I mean it's
very very surprising that we're Pawn up
and we're not able to put a little bit
of a challenge in front of Hobby in this
exact moment as the clock keeps ticking
uh yeah the clock is ticking and uh one
thing to also note that the players are
not allowed to offer draws that's right
at all
so yeah Rook G6 powerful threat
coming up empty uh with ideas myself uh
again our King on B1 if it was you know
easy easy to go to E3 if we could go
King E3 Rook E4 and Rook E6 we could
figure out a way of putting some
pressure on Black's position the problem
is with the King on B1 these pawns are
really just simply too weak and as soon
as we get rid of The Rook on G4 thanks
to the trade Rook
G6 the pawns just fall H4 F4 or D5 and
you can't maintain them you just
can't well uh as we're wind down today's
broadcast let's take a peek at what we
can expect tomorrow Joy do the honors
what do you have for us look at this
this these are some great matchups as
always in the pomi we'll play lenia
Dominguez young Kristoff Duda faces
Richard reports Wesley so against Maxim
VRA whereas Karana faces off against his
country mate Leon aronian and Ali Resa
fuja takes on my pick of the tournament
Anish giri just because of the whole
Wesley so fua Anish gir's fight for the
uh ELO spot the uh rating for the
candidates you're kind of somehow you're
you gravitate towards the fua giri game
just because so much is on the line
exactly uh not just in the sinkfield cup
this is the ratings to watch and what
we're talking about yeah and you see
that there are two candidate spots
available which will be decided on
January the 1st the first one is by
rating the highest person with the live
rating will get into the candidates and
so far fuja is winning that race
2762 giri is not far behind 2754 and
neither is Wesley so and we were also
talking to VAR akobian and he was saying
that lenia Dominguez also has an outside
shot of getting a spot into the
candidates via the rating and he was
explaining to us that this game should
lenir win the game which now is looking
increasingly unlikely that would really
boost his chances again Fabby is not
looking uh to qualify by rating but
Fabby has already qualified thanks to
his result in the World Cup in Baku so
he's not he's not in that contest but uh
that fight for the rating spot Peter
that has always been of great interest
to the world of CH yeah and it's it's
easy to follow as well because the the
the fer circuit is a new thing and I
think a lot of people aren't as familiar
with exactly how the points are
calculated perhaps even the players who
are in contention me too by the way ra
my hand but live rating these days you
can follow day by day there are websites
which will tell you exactly where people
stand on the live rating uh ranking and
yeah ler is just off screen there a kind
of a Dark Horse because if he has a very
good tournament he is perfectly capable
of having a very good tournament here
his uh as as we've established
undefeated in singfield cups uh uh over
the years and uh he could if in
particular if alza for some reason has a
poor tournament it could become very
very exciting
exactly and uh we're talking about the
feed circuit we see there that as you
mentioned there Peter Fabiana Carana is
actually in the clear lead in the 3day
circuit right but he's already got got a
spot from qualifying in the World Cup
right but Anish giri is in second place
and um Five Points behind him it's gash
and then behind him it's also Wesley so
as as she had out
uh a shout out to the organizers in
Toronto by the way because uh it's
Toronto that is going to be the host in
2024 of the candidates so it moved from
Madrid where it was previously held it
goes to Toronto I think that's the first
time Canada has hosted a fiday
candidates um you have to go back to St
John's New Brunswick where they had the
candidates matches I famously uh played
with Jonathan spilman but there was many
many candidate matches and including
Kevin spaget uh played that was really
fun but it's nice to have Canada hosting
and we do have a move or not yeah we
have a move Rook E4 so Lenard has just
absolutely given up the D5 Pawn if you
want to take it Rook takes D5 Rook to
the seventh Rook to G6 that seems
I have a feeling he is planning to play
Rook G5 here trying to improve sort of
Force black or at least try to force
black to trade on G5 to improve the pawn
structure I assume you can maybe even
not trade for a while but even this once
again regrettably just this followed by
King G6 bringing the king up and then
we'll play Rook D4 pick up the pawn on
H4 this this same position with the
white king actually participating in the
game would have been potentially quite
dangerous for black but with how far
away from the action that King is I
don't really view this as a legitimate
winning attempt I think he just came to
the correct conclusion that his position
is just just not better and activating
this Rook on D4 was doing a solely a
defensive job and at least you get it to
a good Square on E7 and um perhaps
Fabby decides it's threatening and does
something else is there a chance to go
wrong so for instance you know your line
rookie for I think if
there's there's a very good chance that
Fabby will capture that pawn on D5 and
after Rook E7 Rook G6 Rook G5 I was
wondering I mean
is even starting even starting from here
if you if you're really unhappy about
allowing Rook E7 this move is fine
because D5 is hanging the only way to
protect it is to go back oh my God and
then we can go Rook F6 and kind of wink
wink not you no draw offers uh pet
I learned something when you want to
repeat the position three times it's
very important that you make eye contact
with your opponents yes absolutely
engage engage and then you're like are
you on the same page as me and then
then no no winking or nudging going on
there and he goes Rook G5 immediately
which is something we haven't really
considered but I don't know if that
changes very much although now Rook
takes G5 will also lose a tempo because
the Rook will get attacked so I guess we
do something else Rook df5 looks normal
Rook ff5 also looks normal right both of
those moves appear to be uh completely F
legit yeah choose whichever one you I
mean I guess Rook ff5 is simpler because
in case of Rook E7 we just transposed to
exactly the line we're discussing we're
just taking from F5 not from G6 and what
else are you even doing here if you're
not playing Rook e Rook E7 King C1 yeah
exactly G6 I me yeah at a certain moment
I I I mean I'm going to have to play C4
and King C2 uh just to get my king into
the game as uh I don't want to leave it
forever on B1 s yeah yeah I know I was
going to say um it's actually very
difficult to come up with a plan Ricky
sain is the only thing that I see and
exactly let's ask the question uh if we
actually take on G5 here are we much
worse I can't believe it I can't believe
it no no h takes we go Rook F5 we go D6
D5 if we start bringing the king over
but maybe don't take with the uh and if
if you do
this we we we come here and King G6 is
even King G6 is fine you can also play
Rook D1 for now to you know keep an eye
on all of our on on B2 is in such a box
that is not playing a true but you're
giving white some chances so the first
thing that I'm looking at is Rook to E7
Rook to
E7 King to G6 I I Rook G4 becomes a
topic and
it's just at a certain moment you bail
you go H5 and he's gone he's gone Rook
df5 which is also very very
understandable my one worry was allowing
Rook E7 but once again arguably this is
maybe an improvement because the pawn on
H4 is more vulnerable you can even do
something like this here and just
counter play enough counter
play yeah Rook F5 that's I was also
wondering can you be extremely cheeky
and
just just allow Rook TT you seven you
you probably can yeah I I I think I
think it's a good shout I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure in this position we're
not losing even if we like I yeah that's
rude that's just rude I know I know you
give me my one thing and we now we're
now a touch Wars like we're this isn't
as clean as everything else we've been
we've been showing but it's still a draw
MH wow still a
draw you know I I I remember an
annotation that that uh Alexander alakim
made made dur about his games and uh his
best games it's a two volume book and
there was this annotation where he was
thinking thinking thinking and it
suddenly occurred to him that his
opponent had laid a trap for
alakin and alakin looked at the Trap and
said you know if I fall for the Trap
that accelerates my
victory
you know you lay a trap and it
accelerates the draw and it's like wait
that work out the way I was planning
very amusingly I have recently uh seen
on Twitter a very similar concept
described as the Shanklin rule the
Shanklin rle which apparently is maybe
in one of his books which is uh easiest
to describe as what if we do it
anyway so what we what they attacked
something and they they're trying to
prevent a move of ours what if we what
if we play it anyway here Rook takes a
for would be a prime example I think
Rook F7 maybe is actually the cleanest
yes speaking about this position Rook F7
I assume l l year will go after this one
we'll pick up the PA on4 cleaning it's
important for us that b before survives
but the pawn on B before Will Survive
there's no way for white to pick it up
and H5 King H6 why are we supposed to be
worse here mhm I have a I have a trick
Peter M instead of H5 M Rook A4 yeah you
want to lose the game yeah c c yeah
you're not going to lose the game you
got a Perpetual have iMed Perpetual also
I'm not forc I understand but I was
going to win The Pawn on B4 I mean I was
going to make
it we have some something happen took on
G5 which we as we've established is also
completely fine it's gone Rook F4
immediately without any Rook F1 Rook H1
shenanigans okay yeah once again
illustrating the fact that H5 H6 is this
massive massive threat H5 Rook F5 we
start actually winning some material so
yeah we we don't really have to worry
about anything here with black this is
headed towards toward very clean draw
peaceful uh signs Dead Ahead uh and uh
for those of you draw uh joining as late
we have had four
draws and the theme of the round is
let's play Bishops of opposite color
position and prove to everyone that they
are drawn and that's what it's been Joy
absolutely and our first opposite color
Bishop that was from Richard report and
npom Nashi and then it was Wesley so and
lza fuja and then giri and Duda and then
finally B grav and leevon aronian but
these guys lenia Dominguez and Fabiana
on it might be another draw but it
certainly wasn't one with opposite color
Bishops and it was one where I really
felt that lanir at a certain moment
Peter if you just don't mind bringing up
that moment where the queens were on the
board and it was you know this
opportunity for lanir to go into a rook
and pawn end game a pawn to the good but
at the time that the queens were on the
board it was a very attractive attack
that he traded away uh staring from
somewhere around here if we although it
feels like the game is about to end so
we can maybe do that once once they've
shaken hands yeah H takes G7 we just on
the board fa will take lineer will play
Rook E6 Rook G6 Rook E7 check I suspect
This Is How It Ends like like black is
even a pawn up now zero winning chances
but clearly a a tremendous moral Victory
a moral Victory is there no chance to
kind of go after Rook to E6 Rook to
D7 yeah yeah actually you can sort of
play on but it's not a hugely hopeful
attempt but ah but you're a por up are
thank you I mean we live for these
moments exactly since no no handshake is
forthcoming perhaps we can discuss what
Yer was queuing up to discuss uh on our
boards uh so in this position on move 32
when Queen E8 was played there was a
move Queen H4 which we just started
discussing but didn't really get around
to Queen G6 Remains the only move after
GF Rook F5 Remains the only move Rook
takes E4 and here black has probably to
play Rook takes D5 resulting in this end
game which is probably okay because
after Rook f8 uh black probably has
enough coun to play but that was
definitely uh at least something to
consider but ler played a very natural
move Queen H3 Queen G6 only move uh Rook
G2 Queen H7 only move and in this
position the choice was between the end
game that ler went for uh which ended up
as we as we're seeing on our screens now
being completely equal and this move
Queen G3 after which you probably have
to play Rook
A8 and the game goes into this phase
where uh because white has no real way
of getting any of his Rooks to the H
file it becomes slower for a time you
play something like Queen F2 black even
has time to perhaps improve the
situation on the queen side with B5
before just to establish some counter
threats and white has choices you can
continue trying to open the Gile or you
can play G5 and say this is a horrendous
piece I want to try and make sure make
sure that it doesn't really come back
into the game properly and um very
difficult to assess positions like even
G7 G6 apparently is playable and white
can now try playing H4 Rook H3 H5 black
on the other flank and try playing B4 A4
B3 uh I think the engine Begins by
thinking this is maybe a better chance
than what uh laner ended up doing mhm
but then then as you can see it actually
drops down to very very equal uh
assessments if you if you let it U run
for a bit per uh yeah and after Queen H7
our first instinct was there has to be a
way to at least make black suffer a
little bit right but no suffering seems
like no suffering no no and the current
position Peter if you bring uh up uh the
exact moment again we know that Fabby
has the pawn but yeah L played uh rookie
1 immediately Rook G5 Rook D1 D5 Rook E1
and basically he is saying eventually I
will attack the pawn on A6 and force you
to play D make a
draw so so what he's saying is he'll
play Rook e 7 or Rook e six or something
and then Rook A7
D4 let's say even Rook A6 check and you
you end up in a position like this where
the Rook is the Ros are sort of reversed
yeah it is now black who has no way
forward because his piness will be
preoccupied by trying to keep these two
guys alive with the King coming up to D3
just as youve prescribed it got it
tickled your funny did I was just
thinking that's this Karma right yeah
and yeah completely right there Peter
King C1 r a no Rook even Rook D6 yeah
because F somehow didn't get the king to
E7 in time so now we get a forest draw
after The Rook Rook D6 so Rook G4 to
defend the D4 Pawn I will play Rook D5
and I'll snip the A5 P yeah I think it's
cleaner to uh perhaps uh the engine here
goes Rook G1 D1 and then meets Rook
takes A5 the eventual Rook takes A5 with
D3 so we we eventually we come
on no I think no no no no no I think G
so you were trying so we do this yes and
after that once once this Pawn Falls we
go D3 C takes D3 and we can even throw
in Rook D2 check to to make sure we're
the first ones to attack a pawn in this
position it's not very important but
it's kind of a nice little moral victory
yeah Moral Moral Victory there for
black yeah Rook G1 on the board King B2
King
B2 well Peter you are the prophet here
predicting this my engine but but I'll
take the
credit thank you very
much
thank you very much that's from Elvis
Presley I mean that was his signature
line thank you very much thank you very
much
okay noted um okay Rook
D5 yeah King
E6 I'm not sure what we're thinking
about rook2 King C1 would be whoa
interesting I have to refresh my board
I'm not exactly sure how I'm supposed to
do that I guess I just go clicking over
here yeah double click on the small
board does and there it goes yep yeah so
he played D3 and he will play King E6
here which is I'm a bit surprised by
this because why are we asking ourselves
to calculate all kinds of Pawn endings
but no it's k6 R A5 Rook D2 check once
again yes but after uh in the current
position after King E6 uh White
has okay so I he's just played King E6
yeah Rook A5 did
just just played Rook takes A5 and
that's the key move what you were saying
uh Peter Rook D2 check winning the
temple I would hesitate to describe it
like as a key
move true this
moment there's probably like
15 first choices here this is a bwn as
well so it means that we can even lose
it and go to the back Rank and that is
still a draw oh my so now uh very nicely
done by ler just giving up on B3 to
hasten the the demise of this game right
so we see uh Chris bird the Arbiter
giving the players 60 moves exactly
score sheet I wanted to say that's
actually quite an effective from them
because inefficient I was expecting R
three here the loss of paper yeah the
extra SC they should have found a way to
end it before move 61 because this way
they and uh
to fill in another they are accelerating
to the the Kings
yes naked
Kings and there we have our fifth and
final draw of the day what a start the
same a strange start as we were so
prepped the enthusiasm we had for the
48% decisive victores Joy we were all
gungho and five draws I think that's the
commentator's curse I think no I think
that the man in the picture here with
our with his back to the camera he was
very much on point Chris bir tweeted
that the chief showing these stats on SC
on air when the round has just begun was
the shest way to ensure to to to to head
us towards the five draws today exactly
well that's to jinx us he said yeah we
got jinx no question about it but if
they were fighting just I mean I mean to
be fair the players all played
exceptionally well you know we can point
to several key moments say for instance
in the Anish giri Yang Kristoff Duda
game you know there was a lot of tactics
there uh levon's game was particularly
well played and here this one was a very
fighting draw yeah know the accuracy
again of the players is just a
astounding and uh even this game uh I
really did think that lanir was going to
be able to ask some questions in this
rook and pawn Ending game I just had no
idea that it was just going to be that
easy and it was that move Rook F6 too in
particular Rook F6 Rook G6 Peter as you
were pointing
out very good until that moment there
were still I think ways to go wrong but
once once he just landed Rook F
six instantly you felt yeah this is a
man who has figured out exactly how to
hold this position and he will hold it
and uh hold it he did very very
efficiently no question about it as the
first round of the 2023 singfield cup
goes into the books five consecutive
draws we
anticipate that one of the players maybe
both of the players will come over and
explain how they did it but again it's
the accurate play of the players Joy
nothing to be done if you don't make a
mistake in chess you're not going to
lose exactly and the players they're
world class yes you can expect them to
play very precise
chess but I very entertaining thoughts I
do we're going to actually change up uh
because the players are actually uh in
conversation they're analyzing the game
we're going to let them analyze Peter do
the honors uh close the show with us uh
final thoughts please we take some of
the blame for the five draws obviously
but it was a very very nice round of
Chess there was one slight non-event
with Yan's game really repeating an
earlier Yan's game from from this year
this one you you can count as a you know
quote unquote Grand Master draw the rest
were really well played they were hard
for this particular game that we just
finished watching was very exciting
there was a lot of stuff that was left
uh sort of behind the curtain with
things that they had to calculate
precisely to land in that drawish Rook
ending that they landed in uh and yeah
final standings will not surprise you
probably uh not very exciting but a
10-way tie for first Joy it is early
days guys it is the standings after
round one after a very peaceful
harmonious day but you know tomorrow we
are going to be seeing a lot more action
on the boards as the players start uh to
play yeah well Jeffy once again thank
you again uh your return to St Louis as
uh heralded great joy and we love the
studio so it's great brought the weather
I brought the drawers more can one ask
for nothing thank you so much for
joining us and spending time with us we
look forward to seeing you tomorrow for
round two of the sink field cup same
time same place same channel see you
tomorrow thank you for watching
[Music]
byebye
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club Club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the St
Louis chess club is
prohibited